Die Nacht, falling down into your life
You said it straight for you
The night comes shining through
Wackelkontakt des Todes
Wackelkontakt
Overwatch
OMEGALOOL
Wackelkontakt des Todes
Wurz spielt jeder, wenn du dich cues in den Match kommst rein, es ist quasi 90% Rennen als Wurz rum.
So, dann haben wir Zombie Charaktere, die kann man irgendwie in der Beta nicht spielen.
Ah, Hauptsache Brustbeheiligung.
So, dann haben wir hier noch Multiplayer Charaktere.
Dann haben wir einmal Torbjörn, dann haben wir Zarya, dann haben wir Sam Fisher,
dann haben wir, keine Ahnung, dann haben wir Soap.
Komm, ich spiele Torbjörn. Nee, komm, ich spiele Zarya.
Ja, mal gucken, wo ich den uninstall simuliere.
Schauen wir mal, ob mich das Game aufregt.
Also man weiß ja nicht, kann es sein, dass das Game so ultra geil ist, dass, ich sag, das wird nicht uninstalliert.
Allerdings, die PC Beta geht ja ganze...
Jawoll.
Grills.
Dass das so geil ist, ne. Aber die PC Beta läuft ja eh nur zwei Tage.
Was halt auch irgendwo bescheuert ist, ne.
Könnt ihr mir mal erklären, wo der Sinn eigentlich davon ist, dass man eine Beta macht,
so nach dem Motto PS4, danach irgendwie Xbox und dann PC und irgendwie Early Access
und regulär erst ab heute Abend und dann zwei Tage lang.
Ich mein, warum sagt man nicht einfach drauf geschissen und jede Plattform...
Kann man eigentlich ins Wasser fliegen? Versuch mal, ins Wasser zu fliegen.
Und jede Plattform eigentlich zur gleichen Zeit launchen, wenn gut ist.
Und ich hab ja auch so, weil jetzt gerade einer in den Chat geschrieben hat, irgendwie
Kotjog PC nicht. Also sie erzählen natürlich jedes Jahr, wie geil ein PC ist und so.
Und dass sie PC-Spieler lieben und haste nicht gesehen und hin und her.
Mal unabhängig davon, also selbst sollte das Game hier übelst geil sein.
Und sollte das voll einschlagen, ich glaube eher, dass es auf Konsole einschlägt.
Das ist einfach so, ich weiß nicht, so die letzten gefüllten acht Teile,
ich weiß nicht, ob das hinkommt, in Kotjog auf dem PC waren und sagen wir so
fünf davon waren halbwegs spielbar. Wie sag ich die Lautstärke?
Passt die Lautstärke im Hintergrund? Bisschen leiser, ein bisschen leiser.
Können wir machen, das ist ein bisschen laut.
Mach mal so, mach mal hier 20. Muss ja was hören letztendlich.
Bisschen laut, oder?
Wir warten mal die Runde ab.
Es ist relativ viel Leerlauf drinnen.
Also man rennt relativ viel rum, das ist schon fast Richtung Puppe,
was das Rubberrennen anbetrifft, allerdings ist die Map kleiner und es ist halt schneller.
Das hat eine halbwegs gute Performance, auch wenn es auf 90 FPS gecapped ist.
Sieht man oben links den FPS-Counter bei euch oder sieht man das Nvidia Overlay nicht?
Also bei mir ist es jetzt gerade 87 FPS und mehr geht nicht.
Man kann es zwar einstellen auf bis zu 250, aber das greift nicht.
Direkt volle Pulle.
Ich will in diese komische Scheune da, das ist nice.
Vor allem wenn man Pech hat, wir kriegen jetzt instant auf den Sack, das kann gut sein.
Es kann gut sein, dass wir instant auf die Fresse kriegen, weil zu dieser komischen Scheune gehen sie alle.
Habe ich das Gefühl zumindest.
Ok, die Scheune geht nicht auf, das ist natürlich ganz toll.
Gehen wir ins Dach rein.
Zack, Midi-Pack, Munition.
Helz.
Schneiber.
Wir behalten das Ding mal.
Gleich mal aktivieren.
Revive brauche ich jetzt nicht, weil ich meine es ist eh Solo.
Ok, next.
Man kann hier übel Sound hören in dem Game.
Hier ist aber nichts.
Wie war der Slider? Ah, C, C ist der Slider.
Auf der anderen Seite ist irgendwas.
Ja, ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen konzentrieren, ich kann jetzt nur zwischendurch Chat gucken.
Schauen wir mal wie das Game ist, ich meine nachdem mich jetzt ja die Battlefield 4 Beta irgendwie enttäuscht hat.
Oh, Physix, Physix, habt ihr das gesehen?
Wow, fuck, das ist das erste Cod mit Physix, mit Bullet-Physics.
Da kann man jetzt nicht einfach mal so drauf halten, das geht nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Schneiber, den bashen wir jetzt da drin.
Ich brauche übrigens noch eine Rüstung, ohne Rüstung ist man... ohne Rüstung ist man instant im Arsch.
Ich gucke mal ob der was hatte.
Der hat Mini Packs, der hat einen Rucksack, ok weg.
Und der hat eine Perk.
Perk brauchen wir.
Ich brauche unbedingt eine Rüstung.
Hier ist bestimmt schon alles gelootet.
Rüstung, nice.
Ich habe irgendwas gehört.
Ja sag mir bitte gleich mal, wenn ich dann auch wieder Chat gucken kann.
Wieder, wieder, wieder In-Game Sound.
Sagt mir jetzt mal, ich gucke in 20 Sekunden in Chat, wie der In-Game Sound ist.
Das passt.
Ich meine jetzt ist auch nichts.
Ich brauche einen Scope für dieses Ding.
Weißt du, kaum sagst du Scope, nebenan liegt ein Scope.
Ich bin ja nicht der große Battle-Royale-Owner.
Also ich kann jetzt hier nicht so am Rand der Zone lang creaken und mich geil finden dabei.
Die stellzen wir uns jetzt.
Alter, piss dich.
Gehen wir jetzt hier rein, da wird er gekillt.
Hoffe ich mal, dass man hier hochkommt.
Alter.
Alter, springen geht nicht.
Sackerwaffe auf Range.
Was ist das für eine Kackwaffe auf Range?
Komm her.
Ich will da rein.
Wo ist er denn?
Alter, wo ist der Dude?
Ich check das nicht, wo ist der denn?
Hallo?
Oh fuck.
MonkaS ey.
Hyper MonkaS.
Next.
Hauen die Lautstärke hoch?
Okay.
Ich mache die Lautstärke hoch.
Ich mache erstmal bei euch die Lautstärke hoch.
Es braucht jetzt so ein paar Runden bis das funktioniert.
Das hat man ja mal im Battlefield gesehen.
Du hast mal auch übelst reingeschossen.
Der Sebaro hat irgendwas.
Twitch Affiliate oder Partnerschaft?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich nicht.
Was?
Genauso leise wie vorher?
Echt?
Ihr seht es ja hier, ich habe voller Anschlag.
Ich mache mal so hoch.
Leute, guckt mal.
Das Übel ist laut.
Also komm, sonst werden wir noch nicht übertreiben.
Jetzt passt es.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn rumgeballert wird, dass es sogar ein bisschen zu laut ist
dann.
Unter der Gürtelgenie.
Eigentlich hätte ich schon längst gewonnen.
Wo ist meine Immersion?
Also falls es zu laut ist, sagt es Bescheid.
Es ist immer schwierig einzuschätzen, weil ich habe hier in-game nichts.
Es ist ein Ticken laut, oder?
Ein Ticken laut ist das schon.
So, gucken wir jetzt mal.
So, wir jumpen jetzt wieder.
Eigentlich will ich immer hier hinten an die Scheune.
Das Ding an dem, also ich sehe es jetzt nicht, ich habe jetzt auch nichts zum zeigen.
Also da, da hinten, da hier.
Die Scheune finde ich das beste.
Beste Scheune.
Da fliegen sie aber alle immer hin.
Ticken zu früh.
Auf, Fallschirm.
Scheune, Scheune.
Komm an Bra, Scheune.
Oh eine Waffe, hier ist immer eine Waffe drin.
Das beste Perk.
Sobald mich jemand anvisiert, höre ich den Sound.
Das Perk ist übelst gut.
Nice, wir haben eigentlich alles was wir brauchen, jetzt können wir ein bisschen was killen.
Wie macht man das wieder runter?
Piss dich.
Alter, ich habe den nicht gesehen.
Monka Giga.
Die Rüstung hat uns den Arsch gerettet.
Nice, aber gleich hier oben, Mini Packs, Rucksack.
Granate.
So alles da was man braucht, noch ein Rucksack.
Weil wir haben ja eigentlich schon einen.
Legen wir uns mal kurz hingucken, was haben wir dann?
Okay, das kann man sich einfach erheilen.
Haben wir das gleiche noch mal, paar Mini Packs.
Die ganzen Kram ein bisschen upgraden.
Was ist das für eine Rüstung, ist das Level 2 Rüstung?
Level 2 Rüstung, ah nice.
Deswegen haben wir eben auch gewonnen.
Oh, da ein bisschen Grafikglitches hier.
Ich bräuchte mal was mit ein bisschen Zoom.
Wir gehen jetzt dahinter.
Komplett.
Solo Style.
Ein bisschen was killen.
Ich habe nämlich vorher übelst taktisch rumgestellt.
Das ist halt langweilig wie Sau.
Da hast du dann am Ende 5 Kills und bist zwar Top 5, aber es war halt 20 Minuten pure Langeweile.
Kurz gucken, wo das Ding hinstellt.
Oh, es zielt einer auf mich.
Habt ihr das gehört?
Das war der Sound, wenn einer auf mich zielt.
Wenn man diese Perk abhat.
Das ist halt mega praktisch.
Hallo, nicht stecken bleiben im Fenster, please.
Ah, Deadside, nice.
Stealth Mode activated.
Sehr schön.
Gucken wir mal, was wir so erwischen.
Ich vermute mal, da war hier in dem großen drinnen der andere Typ.
Hat sich für mich so angehört, als kam das von hinten.
Das Problem ist, ich komme nicht schnell ans am besten hin.
Kann ja schlecht hier übers Feld rennen.
Klick mir den Damage.
Das war irgendwo rechts.
Das bringt nichts, das 90 FPS Cap.
Hauptsache, Health.
Also, Health haben wir genug.
Ich habe ja hier das 90 FPS Cap vom GAM.
Das liegt nicht an der Grafikkarte.
Schnell genug ist der Rechner.
Ich meine, das ist ein 8700K mit 1080 Ti.
Also, das ist eigentlich so immer noch so mit der Schnellste, was man so haben kann.
Wo stellst du denn die Gegner dann alle?
Jetzt leben wir auch nur noch 31.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo sind die denn?
Hat jemand eine Ahnung, wie man feststellen kann, wie beschädigt die Armor ist?
Weiß das zufällig jemand?
Weil das habe ich noch nicht gecheckt.
Von da ballert YOLO, da gehen wir jetzt hin.
Durchs Maisfeld gestellt und dann instant, instant bashen.
Alles bashen.
Die Zone kommt ja auch irgendwo von da oben.
Das heißt, die kommen jetzt hier auf jeden Fall lang.
Ich meine, von unten nach oben ist jetzt immer nicht so der Beste.
Zum fighten.
Gehen wir nochmal hin, bashen.
Hier ist doch irgendwo was.
Hier muss doch irgendwo was sein.
Können die eigentlich nur von hier kommen?
Gehen wir mal ins Dorf.
Es sieht doch nicht so aus, als wäre hier eigentlich schon einer gewesen. Großartig.
Barricade ist angeblich auch übelst OP zum Headglitchen, habe ich gelesen.
Von da oben geht was.
Ich habe immer noch Stellschritte.
Also hören tut es keiner, wenn ich laufe.
Ich meine, es leben nur noch 22, wir haben kaum was gesehen.
Und es ist nicht so, dass wir nicht rumgerannt sind.
Ich finde, am pacing könnte man noch ein bisschen arbeiten.
Wo könnten die dann sein? Also von da hinten könnte es irgendwas angehen, klar.
Von da, da ist was.
Auch mein Stellmodus ist ausgelaufen.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir noch irgendwas haben.
Kann das Krempel einfach beaktivieren, braucht man sonst nicht.
Also hier am Rand war auf jeden Fall irgendwas.
Ja, da geht es doch schon ab oben.
Die Texturen von dem Ding sind ein bisschen kaputt.
Kurz lauschen.
Ich hatte übrigens schon die ersten, die geteamed haben vorhin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo was ist.
Also ich bilde mir ein, dass das der Sound ist, wenn einer auf mich aimt.
Das ist eine Rundgestellte.
Die ist rumgestellte immer im Battle Royale Games.
Wenn es leben auch noch 17 Leute und man findet nichts.
Der Perk ist schon abgelaufen, vielleicht ist es ein Bug.
Keine Ahnung, aber ich bilde mir ein, dass es der Sound da kommt, wenn man anvisiert wird und die Perk ab hat.
Dieses Knitschen da.
Vielleicht ist es ja verbugged und es läuft nicht ab.
Man weiß ja nicht.
Oh, da oben geht was.
Da geht was.
Das Schneebrill.
Ach nee, naja.
Sag mal, fliegt das durch oder was?
Ich habe kaum noch Muni hier.
Echt?
Äh, ich blicke nicht durch.
Ich habe gerade irgendwas aufgehoben und ich das wollte.
Ich muss mich mal pissen.
Piss dich, Alter.
Ja, ist klar.
Ich stelle es mich mal in die Häuser rein.
Wo müssen wir überhaupt hin?
Ah fuck, das ist ja am Arsch der Welt.
Alter.
Wo müssen wir denn hier lang?
Ja, ja.
Ja, das Perk ist verbugged.
Ich höre immer noch, wenn sie auf mich zielen.
A, D, A, D vorne, win, ja so ist es.
Wir müssen gucken, dass wir irgendwie noch vor der Zone wegkommen.
Okay, kann man? Okay, ja, ich habe jetzt nichts attached.
Haben wir hier Barricade, haben wir.
Ich stelle es mir mal voll.
Habe ich irgendwie einen Medipack, das voll hält?
Ah, nice, nice, das nehmen wir jetzt.
Das sind nämlich 200, beste, beste Kit.
Wir rennen jetzt ungeschützt einfach mal quer über das Feld.
Man muss sagen, an sich läuft das Game wirklich gut.
Also du hast keine Slowdowns, ich finde die Animation sinnvoll.
Also im Prinzip ist das technisch gefühlt sich das 300% besser an als PUBG.
Vom Gameplay her keine Ahnung, ich habe das auch zu wenig gespielt.
Also beides, PUBG habe ich auch kaum gespielt.
Das sind jetzt irgendwie auch noch ein paar Runden bisher.
Gucken wir mal, nicht dass du uns von hinten jetzt hier wegstellst.
Das ist auch so Overwatch-Tick.
AD, AD-Spam und Jump.
Wenn man viel anderen gespielt hat.
Erstmal in die Zone stelsen und dann mal gucken, wo was kommt.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, die waren irgendwo rechts, ich muss unbedingt ins Haus.
Wir stelsen jetzt da drüben ins Haus.
Wir lassen uns nicht ablenken unterwegs.
Und campen uns hinter die Tür.
Mehl-Damage, ernsthaft.
Die müssen jetzt ja hier lang kommen, klar.
Da war was.
Habt ihrs gesehen?
Nichts wie weg.
Wir stellens uns jetzt hier rein.
Ah, den flanken wir jetzt.
Ist der down?
Der ist down.
Ich kann mich nicht.
Ich muss weg.
Ich muss mich ganz, ganz, ganz weit weg verpissen.
Ganz weit weg verpissen, sonst sind wir zumindest schon mal in einer Zone drin.
Ich bräuchte was mit Rage.
Hätte ich mal meine komische Waffe mit Visier nicht weg geworfen.
Ah, nice, was ist das?
Was macht das?
Footsteps, enemy footsteps, louder out, das ist gut.
Das ist sehr gut.
Darf sich nur noch der Heli mal verpissen.
Heli, geh weg.
Die Noobs fliegen in Heli.
Ich hör nix.
So, weil wenn wir schon enemy footsteps lauter haben.
Es campt alles, alles campt.
Wir machen jetzt den Randstells.
Wir rennen jetzt nicht in den Circle, wir gehen erst wenn das...
Wie viel Leben, also vier Stück, ist ja nix.
Ich geh da, ich hab irgendwie das doofe Gefühl.
Okay, die Park backt rum.
Okay, von da kommt auf jeden Fall nix.
Die Park ist kaputt.
Oh nice, ein Scope.
Wo machen wir das drauf?
Da, aha.
Okay, sehr schön.
Jetzt haben wir die, jetzt haben wir die Park offiziell wieder.
MonkaS, MonkaS.
Alter.
Wir müssen lauschen, Leute.
Wo ist hier was?
Hier kann ja nix mal sein, ne?
Muss hier irgendwo da sein.
Alter.
Hier ist was drin.
Wer campt hier in der Ecke? Nee, macht er nicht.
Hinlegen, campen.
So, so wie man halt Battle Royale spielt.
Alter, dieses rumgestellt, das geht mir voll auf den Sack.
Ich will einfach in your face bashen.
Was soll das denn?
Das geht mir mega auf den Kekse.
Der liegt irgendwo in der Ecke, der Typ.
Klingt mich jetzt einfach auch in die Ecke und gut ist.
Ach, das ist das Geräusch für die Zone?
Was ist da?
Nein!
Fuck!
Voll verkackt.
Der hatte übelste Rüstung wahrscheinlich auch.
Der hat voll gefressen, ey.
Next.
Da ist viel zu wenig Action drin, ey.
Der schluckt mega, ey.
Ich mein, ich hab erstmal gefällt.
Ich hab im Moment nach links gesteppt, wo ich geschossen hab.
Das war fail von mir.
Aber danach hat der gefühlt drei Magazine gefressen oder so.
Zumindest ein ganzes Magazin.
Und es war auch noch zum größten Teil auf Kopfhöhe.
Also ich weiß nicht, da viel Leben kann er nicht mehr haben.
Aber ich hab keine Rüstung mehr.
Ich könnte wetten, das war das Problem.
Ich hätte nach einer Rüstung gucken müssen.
Weil die Rüstungen gehen irgendwann kaputt.
Ich hab aber noch nicht gecheckt, wann und wie man das sieht.
Das hab ich irgendwie noch nicht gecheckt.
Vielleicht weiß das ja jemand von euch.
Also sieht man das vielleicht am Bild?
Ist das Bild vielleicht irgendwie kaputt oder so?
Oh voll in Arsch.
360 Röhrenjump.
Fast wie Mario.
Okay, die Sprungphysik ist, sobald man in die Richtung springt,
bleibt man auch weiter in die Richtung.
Okay.
Wisst ihr, jeder der mal Bad Company gespielt hat,
der hat so den Hang dazu, sobald er solche Zäune hier sieht,
dass er irgendwie neifen will,
dass der Zaun dann gleich 4 Meter weg fliegt.
Kennt ihr das noch aus Bad Company 1 und 2?
Kaum gemessert gegen den Zaun.
3 Kilometer weg.
Hast du den Key bekommen für die Beta?
Naja, ja offensichtlich hab ich den Key,
aber ich hab den nicht bekommen.
Ich hab auch nicht gefragt.
Weil ich hab mir gedacht, warum soll ich fragen,
wenn man sich für 45 Cent bei einem Key Shop
einen Key kaufen kann.
Wow, da öffnen sie raus hier.
Wir gehen wieder, wir gehen wieder in die Scheune.
Scheune Beste, ich sag's euch.
Das sieht aus wie irgendwie so Dreck,
der vom Heli irgendwie hinten raus fliegt.
Sieht nicht aus wie Spiele.
Oh fuck, wir sind viel zu spät.
Scheune, Scheune, Scheune ist best.
Beta Key von Eber, ja quasi, quasi.
Wenn wir Pech haben, ist jetzt schon einer drinnen.
Alter, flieg runter.
Nein, nicht so an die Ecke, ey.
Scheiße.
Man kann es ja mal probieren.
Der Typ war voll in der Scheune.
Nur weil ich so dumm geflogen bin, ey.
Ja, irgendwie 45 Cent oder so hat das gekostet, der Key.
Übrigens, kennt ihr schon den besten Lull-Effekt?
Der hier, Wester.
Lull, Lull, Lull, Lull, Lull, Lull, Lull, Lull.
Natürlich auch in Kombination mit Lull 3D sehr beliebt.
Da wird es quasi zu Lull 4D.
360 Boxen.
Achtung, 360 Boxen.
Oh fuck.
360 Boxen.
360.
Ah, jetzt.
Einfach mal ein bisschen sinnlos rumspammen.
Wie ist die Performance von dem Game?
Also, es läuft gut.
Es hat halt einen 90 FPS Cap, das heißt, man weiß nicht, wie gut sie wirklich ist.
Wie viel Schuss hat dieses Teil eigentlich?
Also, man, weil 90 FPS sollte ich ja mindestens packen.
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich hab's so ziemlich seit einem Jahr quasi so mit, mit, das, das
Beste, was ihr halt in den PC stöpseln könnt, mit dem 8700k oder 1080ti.
Das heißt, wenn das hier drauf nicht mit 90 FPS läuft, dann wäre die Performance schlecht.
Wie viel halt wirklich geht, wird mich interessieren.
Man kann hier in den Settings, kann man einstellen auf, ja, hab ich ja, Frame Limit, Custom,
kannste glaub ich einstellen bis auf 250, aber das greift nicht.
Angeblich nur für die Beta nicht.
Angeblich nur für die Beta nicht, aber mal gucken, man, man weiß ja nicht.
Okay, wir gehen wieder Scheune.
Wir, diesmal, diesmal springen wir aber rechtzeitig ab für die Scheune.
Also quasi jetzt so.
Gib Gas, Alter.
Ich will, ich will als erstes in die Scheune.
An die Scheune springen gefühlt immer 50 Leute.
So, perfekte Scheune, perfekter Scheunenstells.
Was ist das?
Medic, easy, aktivieren.
Brauch man nicht.
Hallo, aufheben, zack.
Aufheben, next, ganz viel.
Ab, nice.
Die Scheune ist ein richtig guter Startplatz.
Die Scheune ist sehr, sehr nice.
Irgendwo rechts war was.
Ich brauch, ich brauch noch einen Rucksack.
Rucksack, nice.
Springen.
Ich find's halt geil, ne, die haben in CoD viel später angefangen mit diesen Hüb-Animationen als Battlefield.
Am Battlefield kriegen sie es immer noch hin.
Oh, ein ACX-D-Car, hatte ich noch nie.
Nice.
Ey, das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, Leute.
Wir müssen jetzt ACX-D-Car stellzen.
Aber dazu brauch ich erst mal irgendwas, wo ich mich in Ruhe hinlegen kann.
So, hier in die Ecke, beste Ecke.
ACX-D, ah ne, das ist kein ACX-D-Car.
Das ist ein Recon-Car.
Okay, gehen wir mal gucken, wo was ist.
Zu null.
In der Firing-Range-Sensor.
Wo geht hier was?
Wo ist hier was?
Das ist das sinnloseste Gadget aller Zeiten.
Wie kommt man überhaupt wieder raus?
Moment, wie kommt man hier wieder raus?
Hallo, ich will aus dem... ah, okay, F.
Haben wir Respekt gepaid?
Darf man auch wieder raus.
Crapel-Gun.
Ah, null.
Wie kommt man hier sonst hoch?
Ich lerne noch.
Aha, okay, das ist cool.
Das finde ich nice.
Ich habe zwar noch nicht einen Gegner gesehen, aber das ist nice.
Craplaws.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Suche Gegner.
Gegner-Blitz.
Ich finde, das hat ein bisschen wenig Action irgendwie.
Links war was.
Aber weit weg.
Hallo, spring.
Haben die jetzt extra Waffenballistik?
Ich glaube schon.
Also, man merkt das auch richtig.
Das ist nicht mehr, wenn man das nicht gewohnt ist.
Ich will dahin.
Ich will mitbaschen.
Mal Map gucken.
Ja, okay, wir sind mittendrin.
Gibt es Fahrzeuge? Ja, es gibt Fahrzeuge.
Habe ich eine Rüstung?
Wechseln wir aus. Ich habe vergessen, ob ich schon gehitted wurde.
Nice, das brauchen wir.
Da hat mich keiner.
Wo ist denn hier was?
Suche Gegner.
Okay, da hinten ist was.
Ich habe wenig Action, weil ich außerhalb bleibe.
Ernsthaft? Ich finde, die Scheune ist ziemlich in der Mitte.
Oder? Wo ist denn Mitte?
Gucken wir uns die nächste Runde an.
Was?
Headshot. Ja, das war ein Sniper-Headshot. Muss sein.
Anders kann es eigentlich nicht sein.
Scheiße.
So, wir landen jetzt mal woanders.
Aber das war halt schon irgendwie komisch.
Ich meine auf die Range musste eigentlich Bullet-Physik nicht wirklich beachten.
Das war ja auch was.
Okay, wir landen jetzt mal in der Mitte.
Für die, die schon gespielt haben, wo ist denn der Hotspot?
Wo geht es denn hier besonders ab am Start?
Wie findest du Blackout bisher? Keine Ahnung, ich habe viel zu wenig gespielt.
Also ich finde, es hat ein bisschen wenig Action und es hat ein bisschen...
Am Anfang geht es kurz ab und dann kommt gefühlt irgendwie Midgame gar nichts,
wohingegen es dann wieder am Ende abgeht.
Da, wo das Flugzeug als erstes rüberfliegt...
Aber das sind wahrscheinlich keine guten Spots dann.
Schauen wir mal, wir springen jetzt einfach mal direkt ab.
Oh, gleich werde ich gebannt.
Friedhofsschändung, gleich komme ich hier.
Nee, nicht Peter.
Was ist denn so das christliche EQ von Peter?
Kommt man hier raus?
Baustelle?
Okay, wo ist denn die Baustelle? Baustelle.
Da, das da.
Okay, dann springen wir jetzt mal in die Baustelle ab.
Der Vatikan, genau der.
Kommt gleich, werde ich abgeholt.
Die schnellste Art einen Berg runter zu rennen ist natürlich immer noch der 360 Jump.
Die Downhill Jump.
Oh man hat Auto-Aim, man hat Auto-Aim, habt ihr das gesehen?
Man hat Auto-Aim bei Mele, nice.
Oder nicht nice, je nachdem.
Okay, wir gehen erstmal Construction-Seite.
Ihr habt gesagt, da geht am meisten auf das Proje jetzt mal aus.
Was? Raid? Wer raidet denn?
Wer raidet denn? Ich bin zu großer Twitch-Schnub, um das zu sehen.
Wir fliegen da nicht wirklich drüber.
Komm, wir jumpen jetzt mal hier ab.
Also ich meine, diesmal fliegen wir doch direkt über die Scheune, oder?
Da können wir doch eigentlich nichts anderes machen, als nochmal in diese komische Scheune gehen.
Mele, ja klar, Mele.
Perfekte Scheunland, oder auch nicht.
Oh, das ist eine kacke Shotgun.
Hat der du irgendwas?
Keine Ahnung, wir nehmen es einfach mal mit.
Was ist das? Schneiber?
Brauchen wir nicht, nehmen wir mal mit.
Haben wir schon eine Visier für das Teil?
Rechts geht es ab, da gehen wir jetzt direkt hin.
Ich habe keine Munition, oder?
Fuck, ich hatte keine Muni und keine Rüstung. Verkackt.
Jetzt gehen wir aber mal wirklich auf diese komische Baustelle. Wenn es da angeblich abgeht, dann gehen wir jetzt in die Baustelle.
Die Baustelle sieht aus wie die Scheine. Was?
19 Uhr. 19 Uhr ist open.
Ja, 19 Uhr.
Was ich ja auch witzig finde, dass sie immer noch nicht in der Lage sind, auf ihrer Homepage mal ordentliche Zeitzonen zu schreiben.
Ich meine, woher soll ich denn eines wissen, was bitte schön irgendwie 10 PM PDT ist?
Keine Ahnung. Was weiß ich?
Können sie nicht einfach so die fünf gängigsten Zeitzonen hinschreiben?
Sollen sie einmal eine Zeitzone für Europa hinschreiben, einmal irgendwie West Coast, East Coast, Asien, Australien, was auch immer.
Dass man die Krams nicht umrechnen muss.
Man muss eine Runde Ninja gucken, dann kann man mitmachen. Was?
Okay.
Ich gucke aber nochmal, kein Ninja. Außer, wenn ich hier inkode.
Wir springen jetzt direkt in das Dorf. Oh, da springen sie alle ab.
Welches Haus nehmen wir denn?
Irgendwie, wir müssen möglichst random ein Haus auswählen, weil random siegt.
So, hier, random. Das da nehmen wir. Das da. Das ist es.
Das Haus nehmen wir. Und auch direkt oben drauf.
Hier ist nichts.
Oh, nice Rüstung.
Weg. Okay, da kann ich ziel.
Oh, das ist eine Burstwaffe.
Heilen. Heilen so an.
Okay, was hat der Dude? Hat der irgendwas?
Shotgun.
Bam, Shotgun in your face.
Wenn wir schon eine Shotgun haben, können wir die auch nehmen.
Okay, wo sind wir jetzt abgesprungen? River Town. Okay, da geht was anscheinend.
Okay, brauchen wir noch irgendwie ein bisschen Muni oder so?
Ups, äh, eigentlich wollte ich mir nur anzeigen lassen, was das macht.
Rastwaffen.
Links ist noch irgendwo was.
Äh, warum ist denn meine Rüstung weg?
Warum ist denn meine Rüstung weg? Hab ich jetzt gerade die Rüstung da getroppt? Kann das sein?
Hab ich jetzt irgendwie gerade... Moment, jetzt bin ich zu dumm. Ich bin zu dumm für...
Wo habe ich jetzt meine Rüstung? Ich habe irgendwo meine Rüstung getroppt, oder?
Hab ich meine Rüstung... Kann mir das mal kurz jemand erklären, oder bin ich einfach zu dumm?
Wo habe ich denn meine Rüstung jetzt getroppt? Hä?
Ach, Rüst... Ach, der hat meine Rüstung gebashed. Ah. Okay, das heißt, die Rüstung verschwindet einfach.
Man sieht nicht, wie viel Prozent die Rüstung hat. Die Rüstung ist einfach weg.
Ich durfte jetzt auch eine Rüstung.
Das ist, äh, ziemlich kacke.
Okay, kann man nicht durchspringen.
Wir rennen jetzt einfach mal hier hin. Wir brauchen eh noch eine Rüstung.
Rüstung.
Come on, bruh.
Was ist denn das? Oh! Äh, nicht wirklich.
Rüstung. GIF. Rüstung. Hier ist glaube ich schon alles gelootet irgendwie. Wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin? Gehen wir mal hier hoch.
Fuck. Piss dich.
Breckt. Alter. In your face. Jawoll. So soll es das sein.
Pssst. Pssst. Pssst. Hat er gut noch was gehabt?
Crapple hook. Okay, keine Ahnung. Ah, weiter geht's. Stellzmodus aktiviert.
Pssst.
Der Tü... Du bist ja hier.
Next. Nee, den können wir nicht mehr looten.
Hook dich zu hier. Oh, das ist eine... Oh, das ist eine nice Idee. Ja, ja, ja. Das ist eine coole Idee. Das equippen wir jetzt gleich mal, den Hook.
Rennen. Rennen. Zack. Rennen. Hätte ich mal Wurz ausgewählt. Äh, da ist Fitter.
Komm mal, Mason hat zu viele Numbers. Das haben sie aber nice gemacht, dass Mason sogar hier Numbers am Start hat.
Wobei, nee, wir spielen gar nicht Mason. Sie haben es nicht nice gemacht. Vergessen.
Na, Numbers-Animationen kriegen alle. Ist ja doof.
Aber das ist eine nice Black Ops-Referenz, dass man hier die Mason-Numbers angezeigt kriegt, wenn man eben in der Zone steht.
Wow.
Haha. Alter, ich habe kein Herz mehr.
Ey, wo lege ich von dem du das Zeug?
Nice, jetzt kriegen wir 200. Beste, beste Helz. Beste Helz-Stells.
Was ist denn das? Reveal the enemy? Ja, machen wir alles an. Alles an hier. Dead Silence. Zack.
Skul-Skul-Skulker. Skulker. Machen wir auch an.
Ich habe keine Rüstung mehr und Rüstung hatte der Duel auch nicht.
Array. Oh, kack, Black Ops 1-Map.
Sch-Kack-Map. Array.
Haha, der war direkt gefickt, Alter.
So vulgäre Ausdrücke werden hier im Stream natürlich nicht verwendet.
Gebumst wäre okay, aber gefickt ist, lasse ich nicht durchgehen.
Ich habe übrigens Panik, wenn dieser Zonen-Sound kommt.
Da denke ich immer, das ist der Sound, wenn einer auf mich aimt, aber ich habe die Perk ja gar nicht, wenn einer auf mich aimt.
Christen-Stream.
Da gab es ja früher diese Seiten, die so super christlich waren, die dann auch nicht Internet gesagt haben oder Internet surfen, sondern die haben dann gesagt, der Internet-Steh-Segler ist unterwegs.
Das ist richtig cringe, oder?
Der Internet-Steh-Segler.
Das ist mehr als cringe.
Das ist cringe im Kreis.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal hier weg.
Ihr kennt den Kram ja sogar, oh Gott, fuck.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das heute noch kennt.
Ich dachte, das wäre so, was weiß ich, 95 oder so aktuell gewesen.
Okay, wie viel Leben, noch 5 Stück.
Zonen-Stells.
Das machen die ganzen geilen PUBG-Pros auch, das habe ich bei Lost im Stream gesehen.
Wenn man geil sein will in Battle Royale, macht man Zonen-Stells.
Man muss von den Besten lernen.
Nachdem ich nie Battle Royale spiele, muss ich jetzt mir das abgucken, was ich bei zwei Streams von Lost gesehen habe.
Zonen-Stells, dann Instant-Easy-Win.
Aber das finde ich halt ein bisschen doof.
Das ist doch zu wenig Action irgendwie.
Ich meine, diese Runde war schon verhältnismäßig viel, aber was denn?
Fast schon das Battlefield 1 sinnlos weg, Gebäsche von der Seite.
Nein, nein, war es mir nicht.
Es war mir nicht lieber.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich hier?
Shotgun.
Wir haben allen Ernstes, ich habe noch eine kacke Shotgun dabei.
Okay, das heißt, wenn der Ende der Runde irgendwo in einem Haus ist, dann werden sie geklatscht.
Mit der Autoshotgun.
Da habe ich von dahinten was gehört, kann das sein?
Ist irgendwo ein kleiner Stelzer unterwegs.
Nee.
Da habe ich was gehört.
Irgendwo da, die müssen jetzt hier lang kommen.
Oh nice, wir stellen es jetzt hier am Zaun lang.
Da kann ja nicht viel kommen.
Kommt mal hier rein.
Rüstung haben wir.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Aber nice, aber da wo Armour ist, ist ganz gut.
Was macht denn das nochmal?
Ah, Enemy Footsteps lauter.
Oh, das ist gut.
Das ist sehr, sehr nice.
Ein sehr, sehr nicees Perk.
Kommt mal jetzt.
Lege Hände am M-Com.
Wo ist das M-Com?
Da wüsste ich wenigstens was ich machen soll.
Wow.
Gegen den Dude kann ich nicht gescheit fighten.
Aber der muss ja hier rein, der muss ja in die Zone reinstellen, der Typ.
Ich bin in der Zone.
Der Typ nicht.
Kann man hier hoch?
Fuck.
Ich dachte hier kann man hoch.
Oh Mann, ist ja wie ein Battlefield.
Hab ich den gehittert?
Der ist weg, oder?
Kopf.
Mal speichern den Kram.
Ist eigentlich eine, eine nice Runde bisher.
Irgendwo von da oben hab ich was gehört gerade.
Kann man hier genug haben, Helz?
Ich mach jetzt einfach mal alles an.
Aha.
Da ist was.
Was auch immer.
Was ist das?
Es hat gerade einer aufgehoben.
Das heißt da ist auf jeden Fall einer.
So da so.
Wie kommt man hier raus?
Stells bestimmt hier drinnen.
ASMR-Stream.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich hab keine Granate mehr, fuck.
Okay, der Dude muss ja hier raus, klar.
Wo ist der denn?
Der Dude muss jetzt rennen.
Der muss jetzt rennen.
Die Zone stellst ja schon.
Was hält denn der Typ eigentlich aus?
Kann mir mal einer erklären, was dieser Dude aushält?
Okay.
Wo ist das Loot?
Hey.
Wo ist er?
Wow.
Ein nicer Schneiper.
Ich bin hier ganz schön kacke.
Ich hab ein Problem.
Da kommt eine Granate, klar.
Fuck.
Scheiße.
Scheiß.
Ich hab eine kacke Position.
Aber warte, das war eine ganz leichte Runde.
Das war eine ganz leichte Runde, da ging was.
Next.
Jetzt lass mal überlegen.
Was hätte man da anders machen können?
Ich bin da vor dem Typ weggerannt, hier oben auf dem Berg.
Das heißt, an sich war die Pose nicht schlecht.
Aber du konntest halt nicht den Berg hoch.
Ich hätte eigentlich irgendwo mehr in die Mitte rennen müssen, denke ich mal.
Wie gefällt dir das Spiel bis jetzt?
Also das macht Bock.
Aber es ist bei Call of Duty ja immer so, und ich denke mal das bei Blackout auch nicht viel anders,
dass die ersten, sagen wir mal so die ersten 20 Stunden, wenn es hochkommt,
die machen eigentlich bei jedem Call of Duty.
Die haben auch bei World War 2, die haben auch bei...
Sogar jetzt mal zu Battlefield, die haben sogar bei Hardline und so Bock gemacht.
Also die ersten 20 Stunden bei einem Call of Duty oder auch bei einem Battlefield
und bei den meisten Games, die jetzt quasi...
Also Games, die so schlecht handwerklich gemacht sind, dass es halt rumklitscht und rumbuckt und crasht,
da hätten es auch nicht die ersten 20 Stunden, aber das ist ja bei Call of Duty in der Regel nicht der Fall.
Und da macht so die ersten 10 bis 20 Stunden eigentlich fast immer Bock.
Das Problem danach ist, dass du nach den ersten 20 Stunden so das meiste gesehen hast
und dann ungefähr weißt, wie es funktioniert, und die anderen Leute natürlich auch wissen,
wie es funktioniert, und dann fallen dir die kleinen Dinge auf,
die dich quasi am Anfang, als es neu war, nicht genervt haben,
da fällt dir dann auf, ok, sowas wie Ghost und Ghost Pro und den das und das in Kombination ist ziemlich gut
und das merken dann auch andere Leute und dann stellt dir fest,
ah, mir geht es auf den Sack, dass jetzt irgendwie die Hinlegeanimation anders ist, dass es so lange dauert
und dann fängt es ja an, nach und nach dich das Game abzufacken und nach 30 Stunden uninstalled zu sein.
So, so ungefähr läuft das. Meistens bei Call of Duty, bei den letzten zumindest.
Und so läuft es eigentlich bei fast allen Games, die es schaffen, vordergründig nicht komplett broken zu sein,
weil Games, die quasi vordergründig komplett broken sind.
Also warum Puppke, so eigentlich ist es mir immer noch ein komplettes Rätsel,
aber halt somit das erste seiner Art für den Mainstream.
Also wie gesagt, Leute, könnt ihr euch dran erinnern, ich hab Anfang des Jahres oder Anfang letzten Jahres oder,
ne, wann war Fortnite, kam das raus, keine Ahnung.
Ich hab zumindest als Fortnite neu war gesagt, dass wir Puppke komplett die Battle Royale Krone abnehmen,
einfach weil es handwerklich gut gemacht ist und auch durchdacht und von Leuten programmiert,
die wissen, was die machen, ganz im Vergleich zu Blue Things Hole.
Wir gehen jetzt mal dahin, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das ein guter Spot ist.
Ich bin jetzt einfach mal direkt runter getroppt.
Ich seh nix, Wolken in 2k18.
Aber man kann nicht beides gleichzeitig aktivieren, okay?
Shotgun, wir brauchen den kack Shotgun.
Den bashen wir jetzt.
Gehen wir gleich hin, gleich bashen.
Da, da irgendwo war das an den Häusern.
Das war jetzt keine so gute Idee, ich glaub ich direkt hier ist ein kack Spot, den ich nicht kenne, zu trocken.
Aber man weiß ja nie.
Alter, was ist das für ein Dude?
Wonka S?
Ich brauch ein bisschen Gear, hatte der Typ noch irgendwas?
Ich hab doch da grad was gehört.
Sag mal, was ist denn hier gerade los? Was zum Teufel geht hier gerade bitte ab? Hat der was Gescheites?
Ich brauch nen Rucksack und Armor.
Okay, hier wird schon gelootet. Wo gehen wir denn jetzt hin?
Construction site.
Wir haben halt nix, wir haben keine Rüstung.
Wir haben keinen gescheiten Health Boost.
Eigentlich haben wir nix, keinen Rucksack.
Das heißt der Drop Punkt war vielleicht nicht die allerbeste Idee.
Da rennen wir jetzt nicht hin, das wäre total blödsinnig.
Taugtas Gamer, also bis jetzt machts Bock.
Wie ich gerade gesagt hab, so die ersten 10-20 Stunden macht bei Call of Duty eigentlich immer Bock.
Ich brauch Rüstung. Die Rüstung ist ziemlich OP.
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf hab, die erste Rüstung macht 35%, die nächste 45% und die nächste 55% weniger Schaden.
Das heißt es ist ultra OP. Ohne Rüstung kannst du halt nix machen. Ohne Rüstung bist du quasi RIP.
Das ist Dings, das ist Black Ops 2 Map. Ich weiß nicht wie sie heißt. Ihr wisst bestimmt wie sie heißt.
Wie heißt denn die Map? Das ist die Black Ops 2 Map.
Rüstung please.
Kann ich mir anzeigen, welches Level ist? Level 2. Oh sehr gut.
Jetzt fehlt uns eigentlich nur noch ein Rucksack.
Raid, oder? Raid? Ja, genau Raid.
Da kopieren sie einfach ihre Maps.
Die Beleuchtung ist aber anders.
Hier ist nix.
Ich find, es hat ein bisschen, also ja ich dropp jetzt vielleicht nicht zu den geilsten Stellen, aber ein bisschen wenig Action im Midgame hat es schon.
Dann hat Pupke auch. Bei Fortnite keine Ahnung, hab ich nie gespielt. Battle, Dings, Royale, wie hieß das?
Realm Royale hat eigentlich permanent Action gehabt, bis ich verkackt hab. Das ist ja auch wieder so ein schönes Beispiel dafür.
Man hat eigentlich ein gutes Game mit einem guten System und verscheißt dann, indem man das gute System zu einem scheiß System erinnert.
Wie man das bei Battle, Dings, Realm Royale, wie die das so verkacken konnten, verstehe ich nicht.
Die hatten ein richtig gutes System, mit das du quasi nicht campen konntest, wenn du gute Waffen wolltest.
Du durftest nicht campen, weil du hast quasi, dadurch, dass du Gegner gekillt hast, hast du halt eine Währung gekriegt, um bessere Waffen zu craften.
Und jetzt haben sie eben diese komischen Gewehre eingeführt, die halt besser sind und dieses Craften der Legendary Waffe sieht es nicht mehr.
Von da vorne hat jemand geschossen.
Suche Gegner. Give Gegner, please. Wunderhaar. Give Gegner.
War da was? Oder ist das reingepoppt? War da was oder ist das reingepoppt? Ich bin jetzt echt unschlüssig.
Ist halt auch kacke, ne? Weil man das nicht auseinanderhalten kann. Pop-Ins oder wirklich echte Gegner.
Gegner.
Und da hinten war was.
Ich würde sagen, das kam von rechts, ne?
Also genug Heals haben wir.
Von hier könnte jede Menge kommen.
Stölzen wir uns mal hier lang und hoffen, dass hier was kommt.
Das ist reingeploppt. Alte Quake Engine. Ich glaube, also ich weiß, dass das auf Quake 3 ursprünglich mal die ersten Call of Duty ist oder halt auch Call of Duty 2.
Sonst, dass das im Kern mehr oder weniger Quake 3 war von der Engine her.
Allerdings, mir kann keiner erzählen, wie macht man eigentlich seinen Wingsuit auf? Geht das irgendwie, dass man hier runterfliegen kann?
Da ist nix mehr von übrig von der Quake 3 Engine. Nix.
Da rennt was.
Den stölzen wir uns jetzt.
Wenn er uns gesehen hat, sind wir übrigens tot. Nur mal so.
Dann kann er sich jetzt eine gute Pose aussuchen und uns baschen.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock jetzt ewig rumzustölzen.
Wo ist hier was? Wo ist hier was?
Was geht hier?
Baschen?
Hier wird ohne mich gebashed. Was ist hier los?
Kann man hier hoch?
Den schießen wir zum Auto.
Alter, ich brauch... Will ich einfach nur mal Gegner haben?
Ist das doch schwer?
Peter.
Dr.
Tue
Was frisst der denn alter? Was soll der scheiß?
Das ist ja irgendwie gefühlt 5.000 Schuss ey
Heile Fresse ey
Gibt's doch echt nicht
Vielleicht hat die Waffe auch scheiße gegen den
Ja beste 300 HP
Uninstall Ink
Ja es muss ja, der Uninstall Simulator muss ja irgendwie noch
Wir wirst ja noch das Uninstall Setup testen
Das ist halt die, das ist halt so der Flow
Was mir auch bei PUBG nicht gefallen hat
Du hast am Anfang ganz kurz was
Dann rennst du gefühlt ewig rum
Und dann hast du halt mal zwischendrin ein paar Fights
Und dann wird's spannend und das ist irgendwie so
Das ist quasi so, so
Hype, Resident Sleeper
Medium Hype
Und dann vorbei
Du musst einfach in den richtigen Plätzen, ja das kann sein
Oh, nice
Geht, geht, geht das Stream noch?
Ah, es geht wieder
Server Crash
Probier doch mal Titanfall
Titanfall ist dead
Dead Game
Ich muss jetzt mal nachgucken
Hab ich vorhin irgendjemand gehostet und ich hab's nicht mitgekriegt?
Das, das, ähm
Das Perk wo man die Gegner Stabs hört, ja das ist sehr nice
Ne
Hab ich keiner gehostet
Die Map könnte nur halb so groß sein
Also ich, man, ich finde man sieht ja halt gut
Sie haben halt hier ein paar Teile verarbeitet aus Maps die man kennt und dazwischen halt Hügel gemacht
Das ist sehr ungleichmäßig so verteilt
Die Maps, also die Map Teile die halt aus anderen Call of Duty Maps sind
Die haben auch ganz coole Elemente
Ja zum Beispiel dieses Fahrzuggestellte da hinten
Also das zwischendrin ist halt so ein bisschen langweilig
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, also meinen Trailer muss man da wirklich zu gut halten dass die ihren Kram ganz gut supporten
Ja, dass sie den Kram
So, wo ist hier bester, wo ist hier jetzt bester Absprung?
Oh, da, River Town, bam
Bei den Construction Side, wir springen jetzt Construction Side, direkt Construction Side, bam
Die sind schneller als ich, wo, wo, wo
Hier ist nichts
Ah, ah, ah
Scheiße, hey, wer kann denn damit rechnen dass da ein Abgrund ist, Alter
Na toll
Ey, wer rechnet denn damit
Ich hab gedacht, du kannst jetzt runter springen, ein Stück, weil der Typ halt vor mir, man kann so runter springen und dann ist es gut, aber das ist, dass es gleich 30km runter geht, wer konnte denn damit rechnen?
Next
Okay, also wir fliegen jetzt da lang, das heißt wir springen jetzt ab bei, Leute wo soll man, wir haben jetzt Zeit, wo soll ich denn abspringen? Wo ist jetzt hier ein guter Spot?
Welche Programmiersprachen kannst du einem Einsteiger empfehlen? Habe ich jetzt nur in der Schule Lazarus gehabt? Lazarus ist das nicht Delphi oder so? Pascal? Irgendwie sowas? Train Station eats. Okay, Train Station.
Also Einsteiger, Programmiersprachen, da muss ich jetzt erstmal fragen, was willst du denn machen? Willst du einfach nur so grundsätzlich ein bisschen lernen, so von der Logik her oder hast du ein spezielles Ziel?
Also willst du zum Beispiel Winners-Programme machen oder willst du Webseiten machen oder willst du Spiele machen oder was willst du denn machen?
Was? Hate ist ein guter Spot, was ist denn Hate? Hater? Ist Hate das hier, ist das der Damm? Wir springen jetzt mal Train Station ab, das ist da wo wir letzte Runde verreckt sind.
Oh, Wasser-Sounds.
Ha, entlarvt. Production-Value, schlecht, ganz schlecht. Immersion, Immersion komplett zerstört. Achso, Quadrant. Ich hab doch, was weiß ich, ich kenne auch die Standard-Battle-Royale-Geschichten nicht.
Mir fällt jetzt erst auf, als einer gesagt hat, dass es hier wirklich so tabellenmäßig ist.
Okay, wir springen jetzt mal hier an das Seite ab. Voll in die Mitte ist vielleicht nicht die aller cleverste Idee. Wir springen jetzt hier an das Seite ab und stellzen uns hier mal rein und holen uns eine Waffe, falls es geht.
Shotgun? Okay, was anderes als einen Shotgun bräuchten wir schon mal.
Mit Rotpunkt, ja mit Laser, beste. Ich stell's jetzt mit der Shotgun rein, ne? Jetzt wird krasser Shotgun-Stellz gemacht.
Ja!
It's up, train station.
Achtung! Psst!
Shotgun in 2K18, lull!
Psst!
Ich brauche Muni.
Ich hab keine Muni. Das sackt.
Ich hab keine Munition, das ist scheiße.
Reck! Wo, wo, wo? Schnippt! Hat er. Weggeschleibert. Ich brauche Muni.
Hat der Dude irgendwas dabei?
Ah, perfekt. Ich hab meine Waffe gerade weggeschmissen. Ich will die andere, ich will die andere, ich will die hier. Hallo, ich will die Waffe. Ja, dann behalte ich halt die.
Jetzt haben wir einen Schneiber. Der Schneiber kriegt noch einen Scope, was hier irgendwo lag, wenn man es aufheben darf. Ah, das ist ja das Loot-System. Please, come on bruh.
Okay, das Scope darf da nicht drauf. Darf da das Scope drauf? Nice. Okay. Sehr schön. Auf geht's.
Alter, kann das mal weg, die Map? Schlimm. Boom. Das war nix, Kollege. So nicht. Porgas.
Ha, das war schon richtig. Porgas. Okay, Train Station ist ein guter Startpunkt. Da geht was. Da geht was.
Gehen wir mal da drüber. Bin ich schon nie lang. Ah, Quad.
Das erste Mal, dass ich hier mit irgendeinem Auto fahre.
Stopp. Ach so. Nice. Den schlucken wir jetzt gleich. Hallo. Da haben wir nämlich 200 Leben und alles wird geowned.
Da müssen wir uns beeilen. Fahr für Söck, by the way. Ja gut, dafür ist ja als New Call of Duty den aber besten Willen nicht berühmt irgendwie für, ne?
Alter, was die aushalten, das ist doch nicht normal. 3000 Dinger draufgeballert. Ren. Ren.
Der Typ hatte keine Weste, ja? Ja, aber der Typ hat trotzdem viel ausgehalten, obwohl er keine Weste hatte.
AD-Spam on Point. Muss. AD-Spam ist einzig wahre. Aber der Witz ist halt, das bringt halt wirklich was, ne?
Und es ist halt gefühlt jedem Game, was jetzt, also in Overwatch ist es halt extrem, weil in Overwatch gibt es keine, also ihr seht ja hier, das hier hat man so eine gewisse Beschleunigung.
Also man geht nicht Full Speed links, Full Speed right und in Overwatch gehst du Full Speed links, Full Speed right.
Das heißt, wenn du in Overwatch den hier machst, dann jumps du in Wirklichkeit so hin und her und kannst halt nicht getroffen werden.
Vorne war irgendwas.
Nix da. Nix da. Ich dachte, da campt einer oder so. Nix da. Was ist denn das? Okay, hier ist schon alles weggelootet.
Ist ausgelootet. Aber alles komplett weg.
Ich höre links was. Links ist doch irgendwas.
Okay, rennen wir mal hier gerade rüber. Wir müssen mal gucken. Links geht was, rechts geht was. Wir müssen jetzt aufpassen, wir sind hier quasi voll im Sandwich.
Da sieht man, dass die Overwatch gefallen hat.
Wir hauen uns einfach mal den ganzen Kram rein.
Wolkendinger, die sind einfach nur sinnlos.
Sechs Kills, die Runde ist doch ganz nice. Also da start.
Oh, jetzt ist dieses Nvidia Replay Kram wieder abgekackt, ey.
Warum ist das so fail?
Habt ihr das gerade gesehen? Das hat sich einfach ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt schreibt er was.
Ist das jetzt noch nicht in vier Stunden?
Immersion. Voll Immersion.
Das Wasser sieht doch hübsch aus, oder?
Aber Wasser ist ja heutzutage nur auch kein Ding.
Ich weiß doch, kennt ihr noch Wave Race auf dem N64? Kennt jemand Wave Race auf dem N64?
Wo wir gerade bei Wasserphysik sind.
Und Wasser, Wave Race.
Wie viele kann man davon eigentlich anhaben?
Äh, so viel wie man will, oder?
ETF.
Man kann sich, allen Ernstes, man kann fünf Parks reinhauen?
Krass.
Geil, Wave Race, beste.
Und das war eines der ersten Games mit so, mit Wasser und Wellenphysik und so.
Und, ähm, damals ging allen voll einer ab für die Grafik von Wave Race.
Und das ist im Endeffekt jetzt, glaub ich, wie 20 FPS oder 12 FPS. Total wir.
Ja, also heute würdest du sagen, ey, kotz, ja, Wave Race war damals.
Das war der Shit schlechthin.
Okay, wie machen wir das jetzt geschickt?
Ich meine, es leben noch elf.
Wir setzen uns jetzt erstmal in die Badewanne.
Es leben noch elf.
Und von hier oben ist, hier, meine Seite ist eigentlich am meisten Platz.
Also, so von meinen beschränkten, was sind das, Battle Royale Kenntnissen, würde ich sagen,
hier kommen jetzt eigentlich gleich relativ viele lang.
Deswegen stellst du uns hier aber schon mal ein bisschen in die Mitte, dass die uns dann entgegen gerannt kommen.
Array. Freudige Map. Schlimmste Black Ops 1 Map Array.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Oh, das ist ein Heli.
Die Noobs fliegen in Heli. Wir fliegen nicht in Heli, Leute, sonst ist die Runde instant vorbei.
Also, ich würde fast vermuten, von da könnten jetzt durchaus noch ein paar kommen, oder auch nicht.
Gucken wir mal, wir gehen jetzt erstmal auf den Bashroof.
Näh, kommt nix.
Wir müssen uns mal ein bisschen sputen, dass wir da auch ankommen noch.
Berlin Wall, ja, das ist DLC Map.
Berlin Wall war das, wo sie erzählt haben, create hiding spots to get a drop on the enemy.
Und dann haben sie sogar in ihrem Ankündigungsvideo gezeigt, so einen Typ, der mit Ghost Pro in der dunklen Ecke hockt.
Rechts war's, vorne war's.
Nix war's.
Fuck, von hinten.
Outplayed, da sagt das. Outplayed direkt, Alter.
Hanoi war auch ein schlimmer Map, ja.
Aber ich hab's vor zwei Minuten noch gesagt, ne.
So nach dem Motto, rechts ist was, links ist was.
Sandwich, ja, zack, voll reingerannt.
Obwohl, es macht schon Bock.
Es geht auch relativ, also, für so puppige Verhältnisse, finde ich, geht's auch relativ schnell.
Wenn, wenn's weitergeht.
Das ist das, was mir persönlich bei den Parma, wo ich pupp, ich hab ja nicht viel gespielt, ne.
Was mich halt, das war halt sehr, auch realistisch und langsam gemacht.
Das ist ja irgendwie auch das Markenzeichen von dem Game, ja.
Aber es hat halt ewig gedauert.
Ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum die meisten Battle Royale Games eigentlich nicht so mein Fall sind.
Weil das, weil das halt nicht diese...
Ja, weil das so, so geschleiche irgendwie ist, im Endeffekt.
Wir troppen jetzt wieder Train.
Train war gut, irgendwie sieben Kills, Train.
Rü! Was ist das?
Wisst ihr, eine Sache vermisse ich von Overwatch, ja.
Und das ist hier bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling, bling.
Wenn du Headshot machst.
Zumal sie ja eigentlich wissen müssten, wie das geht.
Weil ich glaube, das waren auch die Typen, die auch Blizzard bei Overwatch unterstützt haben.
AD-Spam is real.
Hatte Treyarch nicht Blizzard bei Overwatch unterstützt?
Ich glaube schon.
Beste Map war Demoman Peak an Battlefield 3 auf jeden Fall.
Also Rush, ich würde fast sagen, so eine der besten Maps ist tatsächlich.
Also Demoman Peak ist wirklich eins der besten. Finde ich übelst geil.
Das wird noch gepatcht, könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Treyarch ist ja da ziemlich...
Shotgun.
Diese Waffe gab es doch in MW2 hier, oder? Wie hieß denn das Teil?
Wie hieß denn in MW2 die Auto-Shotgun, die übelst gehatet wurde von allen?
AA-12, ja genau.
AA-12, das war's. Richtig.
Wo dann die Ultranubs in der Ecke gelegen haben und dann...
Übelst einen Herzinfarkt gekriegt haben, nicht weggesprayt.
So, ähm, wo gehen wir denn runter?
Turbine!
Turbine, wir gehen Turbine runter.
Turbine, direkt, volle Pulle.
Volle Pulle runter.
Ok, die fliegen links, wir fliegen ein Stückchen, ein Stückchen abseits und holen uns eine Waffe.
Boah, hier geht's gar nicht rein.
Boah, ich kann nicht zielen.
Ich hab nix mehr. Der Typ hat auch nix. Ich hab nix! Ich brauch was!
Money!
Nein, kein Suppressor. Ok, ja, die nehm ich auch. Hauptsache Money.
Da unten geht noch was.
Hier unten ist Action.
Wir haben keine Armour, das ist kacke. Armour, nice.
Ich hab was gehört gerade.
Gif.
Haben wir irgendwie was zum heilen?
Wer ist es bisher zum Machbock?
Hat er noch Money?
War das Schüsse oder war das? Nee, war keine Schüsse.
Da vorne, da gehen wir jetzt hin. Die holen wir uns.
Next.
Oh fuck, wir müssen hier weg.
Ich bilde mir an, dass da hinten halt noch einer war.
Wenn du jetzt einer von hinten stellst, hab ich echt ein Problem.
Hard Scoping hab ich gelesen am Anfang.
Wie viele Monitore hab ich? Zwei, ja. Allerdings an zwei Rechner. Kein Dual Monitor Setup.
Da geht was.
Ich aktiviere den ganzen Krempel einfach mal. Man weiß ja nie so genau. Besser zu früh als zu spät.
Okay, wir müssen echt noch weit. Aber die Zone ist doch massiv langsam.
Gucken wir noch mal nach hinten. Oh, mein Ohr juckt. Gucken wir noch mal nach hinten, ob da was kommt.
Gibt es hier irgendwie ein Boot oder so, wo man mitfahren kann?
Dann gehen wir jetzt erstmal auf die Map wieder.
Bisschen mehr Action könnte echt sein.
Ja, Model 1887 Akimbo. Das war auch er. Das gab es ja zwei Varianten in MW2.
Also als es nicht gepatcht war, wurde ganz normal einfach links und rechts eine Model genommen hast und mit übelster Range und alles gebashed hast.
Und danach musstest du ja irgendwie doppeltes Attachment drauf machen, dass der Patch nicht mehr gewirkt hat.
Und es war noch schlimmer als vorher. Ja, das waren noch Zeiten.
Model 1887 Akimbo.
Oh, B-Scheiße. Bam, tot, bam, tot, bam, tot.
Ich habe hinter mir was gehört.
Engineer war ein nicer Perk.
Da vorne ist was.
Alter.
Ich weiß nicht wo.
Stell es einfach mal hier lang.
Spaß. Bestes Secondary.
Model 18. Also du hast ja die Models als Primärwaffe genommen im Endeffekt.
Das war nice. Das war echt so nice.
Wo will der lang?
Der ist ins Wasser gefahren. Kann das sein?
Oh, B-Schen.
Der muss doch hier sein.
Komm her.
Was frisst der denn? Alter.
Was ist das denn?
Ich meine, was soll ich denn da noch drauf schießen?
Gebatet. Massiv gebatet.
Also das Kräfteverhältnis von Rüstung zu Keil.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass der keinen Damage gefressen hätte.
Der hat ja volle Hits gekriegt, aber das ist nichts passiert.
Also das mit der Rüstung geht mir wirklich ein bisschen auf den Keks.
So eine PC, was sonst? Eindeutig.
Achso, ja genau.
Welche Sprachen wären denn am besten für Websites und Desktop-Anwendungen geeignet?
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Dinge.
Aber wenn du wirklich eine Sprache willst für Desktop-Anwendungen und Websites,
dann bleibt dir eigentlich nur JavaScript.
Dann bleibt dir wirklich nur JavaScript übrig.
Kannst du Websites mitmachen und du kannst mit Elektro- und Desktop-Anwendungen drauf machen.
Ich bin kein Fan von Elektro- und Desktop-Anwendungen.
Wir wechseln jetzt mal. Wir spielen als Daria eine Runde.
Wie spricht man Java aus? Man spricht Java-Java aus.
Aber das ist umstritten.
Es ist umstritten. Ich kenne auch genug Leute, die sagen Java.
GIF oder JIF? GIF. Eindeutig GIF.
Und da gab es noch irgendwo eine Erklärung dazu,
warum es GIF heißt und nicht JIF.
C oder Assembler?
Wenn ich mich zwischen den zwei Dingern entscheiden müsste,
dann ein Deutsch Assembler.
Ja, nicht ernsthaft. Du kommst hier nicht raus.
Direkt.
Ach, da ist ein Fenster.
Kann man in 10 nicht auch ein Assembler schreiben?
Wo geht es lang?
Da. Hydro da.
Nein, Trainstation. Wir springen wieder trainstation ab.
Das war bisher am besten trainstation.
Wir machen wieder die gleiche Sache wie vorher.
Wir springen vorne ab und holen uns hier erst mal eine Waffe.
Bevor wir in die Mitte springen. In die Mitte springen ist Selbstmord.
Ich höre da irgendein Dude rumrennen.
Lekt.
Kann das sein, dass ich einen Sniper habe?
Ist das ein Sniper? Ich glaube, das ist ein Sniper, den ich hier habe.
Fuck. Ich habe ihn nicht gesehen. Wo war er?
Wo war er?
Ach, hinter mir. Gar nicht vor mir.
Train ist halt schon in your face.
Vielleicht sollten wir doch nicht mehr mitten drin abspringen.
Hast du schon mal was in basic gemacht? Nee.
Und was kannst du sonst zum Lernen empfehlen?
Für JavaScript gibt es jede Menge Tutorials auf YouTube.
Ich kann dir jetzt gerade aus dem Kopf keinen Channel empfehlen.
Bücher weiß ich nicht. Ich habe noch nie ein JavaScript Buch gelesen.
Ich habe schon Bücher gelesen.
Doch, ich habe schon Bücher gelesen. Ich wusste Bücher gelesen.
Ich habe nie gerne Bücher gelesen. So in der Schule und sowas.
Aber ich bin kein Bücherleser. Ich lese online. Bücher online, aber nicht offline.
Also echte Bücher. Ich habe ein paar Seesharp-Bücher, aber die sind auch schon Jahre alt.
Wollen wir... Nein, wir tropfen nicht Nuke Town.
Erray. Wir gucken jetzt mal Erray an.
Erray. Runter.
Presse F. Hallo, ich drücke F.
Jetzt. Hart gebackt.
So, gehen wir mal irgendwo in diesen komischen Container hier vorne.
Okay, wir gehen in den hinteren Container. Ich habe es mir anders überlegt.
Da ist irgendein Typ drinnen.
Was? Piss dich alle.
Fuck. Alter, keine Scheiße voll verkackt.
Voll verkackt.
So. Ich würde sagen, beste Gelegenheit, da bin ich eigentlich schon on.
Da bin ich schon on. Sieht man das hier irgendwo?
Zwei Stunden. Na komm, eine Runde machen wir noch.
Die hat sich halt nicht outplayen lassen.
24 Stunden Stream, ist klar.
Ich glaube, nach einem 24 Stunden Stream könnte er mich direkt begraben.
Das halte ich nicht aus. Das kriege ich dann mal hin.
Am besten 24 Stunden Stream und dann arbeiten gehen danach.
Also man muss ja sagen, es hat deutlich besser geklappt, als ich nicht sinnlos direkt abgesprungen bin am Anfang.
Wir machen jetzt doch mal, wir fliegen von da rein.
Cargo Docs. War das nicht der Black Ops 3 Map?
Können wir mal ausprobieren.
Irgendwann Docs.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das 5 Tage in der Woche zu arbeiten früher gemacht habe.
Wollen wir uns mal Nuke Town angucken?
Wenn wir hier gerade lang fliegen, wollen wir mal Nuke Town gucken?
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das ausschaut.
Der Modus heißt auch noch Black Ops, dass sie das am Anfang sagen können.
Ansonsten habe ich hier nichts gefunden, was mit Black Ops zu tun hat.
Direkt runter, Nuke Town.
Direkt Nuke Town.
Die Runde wird halt nichts, wir sind vom Arsch der Welt und ewig lang.
Der Typ ist schon unten, guckt es euch an.
Fliegen wir jetzt halt hinter.
Das sieht gar nicht aus wie Nuke Town.
Oder?
Sieht das aus wie Nuke Town?
Ich finde nicht.
Das sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie Nuke Town.
Oder? Das sieht aus wie Genugte Nuke Town.
Wo ist denn der Tutor, der hier noch runter gesprungen ist?
Irgendwo ist noch ein Typ hier runter gesprungen.
Wahrscheinlich hat er sich schon längst verpisst.
Also das ist kein guter Absprung Ort.
Achja, wir können ja noch mal, eine Runde müssen wir noch spielen.
Wir müssen noch bei den Zombies mal abspringen.
Es gibt ja wohl hier auch eine Zombie Map.
Ich höre was.
Psst.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr ey.
Die fressen alle so viel Zeug.
Wir springen jetzt noch mal auf der Zombie Map ab und dann ist Uninstall Simulator angesagt.
Ich meine, wir hätten ja einen krassen AD AD Spam machen können.
Haben die eigentlich Dedicated Server? Ich würde mal sagen ja.
So, wo ist das denn? Wo ist die Zombie Map?
Da, das hier. Das ist die Zombie Map.
Das heißt, da können wir jetzt irgendwie hier rüberfliegen. Mal gucken.
Doch, das ist bestimmt, das sind bestimmt Dedicated Server.
Die machen ganz bestimmt nicht hier ein 80-Mann-Game auf einer PS3 oder auf einer PS4.
Kommt das eigentlich auf Xbox 360 und PS3 noch raus?
Die letzten Teile haben sie so halbherzig noch rausgehauen auf PS3 und Xbox 360.
Battlefield ist doch seit Battlefield 3 nicht das gleiche.
Ich wäre froh, wenn das seit Battlefield 3 das gleiche Spiel wäre.
Battlefield 3 war beste. Battlefield 4 ist mittlerweile auch ziemlich gut.
Hardline eigentlich gar nicht mal so scheiße, aber das Setting war voll verkackt.
Und auch die Spielmodi. Tja, und eins und wahrscheinlich fünf kannst du voll vergessen.
So, wir fliegen jetzt direkt mal zur Zombie Map rüber.
Gucken wir uns das an. Wo ist das denn?
Da drüben das, oder? Gucken wir mal, ob wir da überhaupt hinkommen.
Also ich würde sagen, ganz dahinten ist die Zombie Map. Ganz dahinten, hinter dem Damm noch.
Oder ist das der Damm? Ach nee, das hier. Das hier ist die Zombie Map, oder?
Das müsste die Zombie Map sein.
Zack, gleich aufs Dach.
Nichts da.
Ich hab da irgendeinen Typ noch gehört hinten.
Alter, was halten die Gegner aus?
Zombies!
Oh, was denn das?
Das ist irgendeine Zombie Gun, ne?
Jetzt brauchen wir bloß noch ne Rüstung.
Und wir müssen schon mal Richtung Map rennen.
Ich höre was. Ich höre ne Zombie.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal los langsam.
Das Ding ist halt so weit außen vor, dass das glaub ich, dass das wahrscheinlich keiner hier irgendwie drauf spielt.
Wahrscheinlich ist es eher so gimmickmäßig dabei.
Wir brauchen ne Rüstung, wir brauchen ne Rucksack, wir brauchen Granaten, wir brauchen im Prinzip alles.
Was kann das Ding eigentlich? Ich will damit nicht schießen, weil ich hab nur 20 Schuss.
Was? Wie der Leben verloren hat.
So, wo müssen wir jetzt eigentlich hin? Okay, wir sind gleich auf der Map.
Da vorne wird schon rumgeballert.
Da hinten wird rumgeballert. Ich weiß nicht, warum irgendwo mit rumgeballert.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir ne Rüstung finden. Irgendwas.
Ja, Bandagen sind hier verkehrt. Aber so ne Rüstung hätte noch was, oder?
Eine nice Rüstung.
Was hab ich da eigentlich auf E?
Was soll ich das nennen? Ist das so ne Claymore quasi? Ist das irgendein Zombie Map Ding?
Hallo?
Behalten wir mal das Teil.
Oh. Wo?
Lol.
Wat?
Das ist räudig.
Alter, ich hab keinen Bock mehr, dass keiner verreckt. Moment, haben wir uns gegenseitig gekillt?
Nee, ich hab den gekillt, mich an einer von der Seite gekillt.
Weil im Killfeed hat man den eben oben gesehen. Ich hab den gekillt.
Komisch.
Wat? Omega-lul? Ja, Omega-lul.
Killcam. Gibt's ne? Oder gibt's ne Killcam? Keine Ahnung.
So. Genug für heut. Reicht.
Wie levelt man eigentlich?
Ah. Moment. Next Level ist vier und ich bin noch eins? Oder versteh ich die Anzeige nicht?
Ach, gibt es? Okay.
Shop. Ganz wichtig. Der darf ja nicht fehlen. Nope.
Was gibt's denn zu bieten? Okay. Also, lass uns da gucken, was es gerade noch mal an.
Also, es gibt die Standard Edition. Da ist das Game dabei. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Und? Ah, und 1100 Call of Duty Points. So, so.
Wozu braucht man die dann? Wahrscheinlich für irgendwelche Skin-Lootbox-Geschissen wieder.
So, Deluxe Edition. Was haben wir da drin?
Black Ops 4 Game. Black Ops Pass. Sternchen. Interessant. Sternchen.
Black Ops Pass Content is not final. Okay. Also, quasi gib mir dein Geld und weiß nicht, was du dafür kriegst.
Okay. Hier ist ein, wie auch immer gearteter Black Ops 4 Pass dabei. Und 2400 Call of Duty Points.
So. Und dann gibt's die Digital Deluxe Enhanced Edition. Man muss sich mal überlegen.
Man gibt hier 130 Euro aus und das ist digital. Also, es ist nicht so, dass man für 130 Euro eine Figur oder irgendwie was, was materielles kriegt.
Nein, das ist digital.
So. Was denn da drin?
Ist doch genau das gleiche, oder? Ah, man kriegt, man kriegt für 30 Euro mehr nochmal Points.
Das ist so die typische Taktik, dass die Leute denken so nach dem Motto, ach komm, für die 30 Euro mehr kriege ich ja quasi auch viermal mehr Call of Duty Points.
Oh, das lohnt sich aber. Ich mein, das ist doch der Witz. Guck mal, 130 Euro. Du kriegst im Endeffekt das Spiel, das ist ja auch das Mindeste.
In den Black Ops Pass, wo man nicht genau weiß, was drin ist. Und 8500 Call of Duty Points. Was macht man damit eigentlich? Das müssen wir jetzt mal nachgucken.
Was, was macht man denn damit? Ich geh mal nicht auf den Keks.
Was macht man da? Call of Duty Points. Prings Back, Code Point, Microtransaction. Jawoll, endlich.
Reflame die Leute schon zu den Editions? Ok, was genau macht man mit den Punkten denn?
Schriftgröße, muss so sein, beste. Ja, beste Schriftgröße. Ich mach das ja nur, dass ihr was seht.
Ok, was, was gibt's denn da vorne? Es ist zu erwarten, dass die Preise... Ok, was, was macht man mit den Punkten? Das kann halt so schwierig sein.
Code Points are back. Jawoll, ich hab endlich drauf gemacht. Ok, gehen wir nochmal irgendwie.
Cosmetics leaked. Wie man diese Pop-Ups auf den Keks... Specialist Outfits. Vielleicht kann da so als Fake Ghost rumrennen.
Also im Prinzip haben wir eigentlich keine Ahnung wofür die Coins letztendlich gut sind. Wahrscheinlich für irgendwelche Cosmetics.
Haben die eigentlich, wisst ihr ob die irgendwas gesagt haben dazu, ob es wieder Waffen geben wird mit unterschiedlichen Stats zu kaufen?
Also das gab's ja in... Was war das? Black Ops 3? Endurance Warfare? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Da konnte man sich doch Lootboxen kaufen und dort sind Waffen getroppt mit leicht unterschiedlichen Stats zu den normalen.
Ist das wieder so? Suchen wir mal nach. Black Ops 4 Pay to Win.
Infinite Warfare, ja die hatten auch so einen Kack.
Wie hieß das? Black Market? Ok, man weiß dazu quasi noch nichts. Black Market.
Ach nee, das ist der Multiplayer Black Ops 3. Sehen die Logos ja auch so ähnlich aus. Ok, also man hat keine Ahnung, wenn ich das jetzt mal so zusammenfassen darf.
Und die Frage ist halt, was man damit macht. Wahrscheinlich Cosmetics.
Ja, das wissen wir ja. Dass es Currency gibt, haben wir schon gecheckt. Allerdings, man weiß nicht, was es dafür gibt.
So, jetzt kommen Google Hacks. Stellen wir mal einen letzten Monat neue Informationen. Wikipedia ist immer erstaunlich gut bei sowas.
Jaja, dass die kritisiert werden, ist mir schon klar. Ok, man weiß es einfach nicht.
Man hat Schlüchterkleidung, keine Ahnung, wie es aktuell aussieht.
Ach komm, eine Runde. Eine Runde können wir noch spielen, oder? Komm, eine Runde spielen wir noch. Jetzt haben wir wieder ordentliche Drop-Punkt.
Was? Ich glaube, es war Belgien. Ja, genau, es war Belgien.
Belgien ist wahrscheinlich so eine Art Glücksspiel und Lootboxen sind nicht erlaubt.
Und jetzt haben sie Panik da. Das gefällt ihnen gar nicht. Manche Leute sind jetzt quasi so nach dem Motto, oh nein, Lootboxen wurden entfernt.
Das ist ja voll schlecht, jetzt kann ich mir keine Lootboxen mehr kaufen. Oh, ist das schlimm.
Und sind jetzt quasi da richtig, richtig stinkig darüber, dass sie keine Lootboxen mehr kaufen können.
Und es gab für, wie hieß dieses Herr der Ringe Spiel, Shadow of Mordor, gab es einen Lootbox Patch.
Genau, es gab einen Lootbox Patch, dass man das überhaupt wieder richtig spielen kann, weil da haben sie halt einfach eingebaut, dass du ewig...
Das hängt, das Game ist gecrashed, easy clap, easy crash.
Boah, niceer Sound. Ah, weg. Weg. Starten.
Zumindest haben sie bei dem Game jetzt Lootboxen und den ganzen Krams quasi rausgepatcht, plus das Gameplay geändert, weil du am Anfang,
Schwachsinn, weil du am Ende, wo sie halt es so nervig gemacht haben für die Spieler, dass sie eben einen großen Anreiz hatten, Lootboxen zu kaufen,
weil du dann ewig rumgrinden musstest, haben sie jetzt quasi, sie mussten das anpassen, weil das sonst nicht mehr spielbar war, ohne Lootboxen.
Da sieht man mal, dass halt auch diese Geschichte von wegen das, ja es ist ja nur rein kosmetisch, dass das selbstverständlich Auswirkungen aufs Gameplay haben kann,
weil wenn man als Entwickler quasi, guckt euch mal Battlefront an, bei Battlefront 2 musstest du ja wohl irgendwie, um Luke oder Darth Vader zu spielen,
musstest du ja gefühlt 5 Monate grinden oder du hast den Lootbox gekauft und natürlich hat das Auswirkungen aufs Gameplay, auch wenn es nur kosmetisch ist.
Da machst du halt den grind so lang, dass es den Leuten auf den Sack geht. Wo ich es irgendwie noch ganz okay finde, ist wie es in Overwatch gemacht ist,
ich meine ja, es ist letztendlich der übelste Cashkauf für Blizzard, ich hab eh das Gefühl, dass es sehr viele Leute gibt, die einfach nur Overwatch spielen,
um mit den Skins zu spielen und nicht um Overwatch zu spielen, dass man damit wohl richtig dicke Kohle machen kann.
Es gibt so viele Leute, die spielen nur Quickplay und spielen auch nur einen Charakter, den sie mögen, mit nur diesen Skins, den sie mögen
und kaufen sich immer bei jeder Aktion gleich 50 Boxen, dass sie neue Skins für ihren Lieblingscharakter haben.
Also in Overwatch ist es halt der übelste Cashkauf für Blizzard, aber ich finde irgendwo, dass es von den Systemen her, finde ich es in Overwatch am verträglichsten.
Wobei ich halt sagen muss, selbst da, hier sind wir vorher übrigens runtergefallen, selbst da finde ich es insofern kacke,
weil dadurch, dass man halt Skins macht, um Skins verkaufen zu können, entfällt halt Skins als Belohnung komplett.
Man bekommt halt in Overwatch, bekommt man eine Kiste bei einem Level Up, ja schön und gut und halt ja, weil man kann sich seine Goldwaffen und so kaufen,
aber man könnte halt auch sonst Skins für Belohnung einbauen, zum Beispiel gibt es ja in Overwatch Challenges für die unterschiedlichen Charaktere,
manche gar nicht so einfach, zum Beispiel diese Lucio Wallride Challenge, irgendwie kille, kille drei Gegner in der Luft oder sowas, das ist abartig schwer
und dafür könnte man Skins Belohnung geben, weil sonst hat es irgendwie überhaupt keinen Anreiz diese komischen Achievements oder Challenges zu machen.
Wenn man dafür coole Skins kriegen würde, das wäre schon echt nice, aber das geht ja nicht, weil die Skins will man ja verkaufen.
Tomahawk, bam, beflasht. Wie fliegen wir eigentlich? Wir fliegen mit dem Array.
Tropfen wir mal da. Oder tropfen wir Construction, ach nee Quatsch, wir kommen ja von da, Docs. Tropfen wir mal Docs.
Doccarino. Oh Gott, hört mir auf Leute, dann habe ich mich schon wieder komplett verdrängt.
Äh, Apfelnudel, ich habe leider nur bis jetzt zu 11 das Comment gelesen, weil die Runde jetzt losgeht.
Äh, ich gucke mir die Games schon ernsthaft an, allerdings gefallen mir die meisten Games nicht, das ist ja das Problem was ich habe.
Wo gibt es hier Waffen? Ich bin hier noch nie getroppt. Äh, Waffen? Wo gibt es Waffen? Waffen? Alter, wo gibt es was?
Ah, da ist was, äh, watt, Moment, hä? Da ist was, der wird geblasht, waaah, nimmst dich.
Oh, Outplayed, fick dich, weg, weg, jetzt kann ich gar nicht ertragen, dass er mich Outplayed hat, voll Outplayed.
Alter, reingeslided, kleines Slider-End.
Schreckt. Oh, ha, Crash, Crash, Crash, noch mehr Crash.
Tja, das Game möchte glaube ich aninstalled werden. Komm, eine ordentliche Runde müssen wir jetzt noch spielen, das war ja eben wieder komplett für den Arsch.
Irgendwo getroppt, wo man keine Ahnung hatte, dann irgendwie von der Seite weggeschnetzelt.
Ok, jetzt kann ich das Comment von Apfelnudel nochmal lesen.
Warum ist es so laut?
Also, mich interessiert, wie du trotz der Aufregung über die aktuell kaputten Videospiele, aber trotzdem noch Aktuelles wie Blackout spielst. Nur aus fanernsthaftem Interesse, ich gucke es mir nur an, mich lustig zu machen, was aus meinem Hoppy wurde, völlig überrascht zu werden, wie gut es ist.
Punkt B habe ich auch. Punkt B habe ich auch. Also bei mir ist ja mittlerweile so, dass sowohl Battlefield als auch God überhaupt keinen Bonus in dem Sinn mehr hat. Ich gehe da auch mit der Einstellung ran, dass grundsätzlich das Spiel erstmal nichts taugt.
Das heißt, das Spiel muss mich wirklich überzeugen, dass es gut ist, wenn es dann rauskommt. Und nicht der ungedrehte Fall. Wo ich ja auch früher ein bisschen zu stark gefanboyt habe in der Richtung.
Und Battlefield 5 hat es nicht wirklich geschafft. Battlefield 5 hat es in Ansätzen geschafft. Da muss ich aber viel tun.
Und ansonsten interessiert mich da schon, was die draus machen. Klar. Ach, wir sind wieder da. Kann man ins Wasser fliegen?
Gucken wir doch mal, wie weit man hier rausschwimmen kann. Wir haben ja Zeit. Schauen wir uns mal an, wie detailliert die Unterwasser-Map ist.
So wie es jetzt aussieht, gar nicht. Spielst du eigentlich auch Hearthstone ab und zu mal? Ganz selten. Ganz ganz selten. E-Sports, lull.
Aber wir hatten heute schon, zwar nicht jede Runde, aber wir hatten heute schon ganz gute Runden.
Fisch-Kai. Stimmt, wo ist die Fisch-Kai? Fuck. Fisch. Wo ist die Fisch-Kai? Stimmt eigentlich, ja. Ok, es raucht durch, seht ihr?
Es raucht durch die Wasserdecke. Oh, wow. Was ist jetzt los? Was ist das? Jetzt kommen gleich die Tentakel von unten raus.
Ah, der Cryin hat quasi mit dem Hintern gerade auf dem Meeresboden. Schlamm, Schlamm, Schlamm. Blackout. Schaut krass an.
Ok, wo wollten wir eigentlich springen? Diesmal, komm. Diesmal gehen wir in Newtown. Letztes Mal war ja da nichts. Aber diesmal gehen wir in Newtown.
Komm, volle Pulle. Newtown. Das wird wieder keine gescheite Runde. Ich sehe es schon, komm. Wieder viel zu random Winston getroppt.
Wieder der letzte Kacknoob. Sag mal, ist der E-Ax zufällig da? Rein zufällig? Der E-Ax am Start?
Fuck!
Ah! Alter! Drecksgame, ey. Ich wollte den Typ Tomahawk, aber dann wurde er von der Seite gebashed. Kacke.
Komm jetzt doch mal noch ordentlich runter. Das ist doch gerade voll räudig, ey. Wollten die nicht unlimited FPS machen? Ja, das, ähm, ich dachte eigentlich auch.
Aber in der Beta ist es wohl auf 90 beschränkt. Die sagen nur in der Beta. Ich bin da, ich weiß nicht.
Gucken. Wir wollen, Meinung zu Cyberpunk. Kann ich nichts zu sagen. Ich hab mir den Trailer angeguckt.
Das hat mich jetzt weder, sondern nicht umgehauen. Noch, ich muss sagen, ich bin kein großartiger Fan von so Zukunftsstellen.
Also wenn ich die Auswahl habe, sag mal, hängt das Game wieder? Kann das sein? Was ist jetzt gerade los?
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hab zwischen Mittelalter-Stellen und Cyberpunk-Zukunftskrams, dann nehm ich immer Mittelalter.
Okay, ich glaub, das Game hängt wieder. Also mich hat der Trailer irgendwie kalt gelassen, ich weiß nicht.
Das sah halt aus wie so ein bisschen Fallout-mäßig. Nein! Das war eine Setting schön, wie sie sind.
Ja, doch, das Cap kannst du erhöhen auf, glaub, 250, aber es bringt nix.
So, jetzt aber, komm. Come on, brah. Moment, hab ich auch Solo gequeued?
Also guck, man kann hier einstellen. Moment, hier. Man kann hier irgendwo einstellen, FPS-Limit, das hab ich auch hochgestellt auf 300, aber bringt nix. Geht nur bitterlich.
Jetzt läd's, läd's, läd's. Das wird der erste Win. Poggers, ja. Dann spring ich jetzt mal ordentlich ab.
Oh, guck mal. Ich will da hoch. Ich muss da hoch. Ich will das Auto haben.
Handbrake. Die Handbrake ist ne Lupe, so so, ne Hupe. Physics.
Wir fliegen direkt über Firing Range. Dann springen wir ein bisschen an der Seite ab, holen uns Waffen im Haus und dann geht's ab.
Alles droppt hier, alles droppt. Uninstall, wenn. Hier nach.
Ne, ich uninstall gar nicht. Ich uninstall erst, wenn die Beta-Phase abgelaufen ist. Wir kriegen aber sagenhafte drei Tage Beta, ja.
Okay, keine Hits. Wo ist denn der Dude? AD-Spam on point. Ich kann nicht mehr zielen. Ich bin...
Okay, ich muss weg.
Ich brauch, ich brauch Muni. Hier ist nix. Ich brauch ne Waffe. Keine, da war keine Waffe da.
Wenn man halt zielen könnte, wäre der Typ down gewesen. Den bashen wir jetzt.
Wo sind sie denn? Alter, ich glaub's net. Altes Game.
Okay, Leute, wir spielen nicht weiter. Das Game möchte nicht, dass wir weiter spielen.
Das ist jetzt glaub ich viermal hintereinander abgekackt.
Ich weiß ja nicht so, dass der Rechner instabil wäre, damit er jetzt hier beim Streamen ja auch abkacken. Aber es kackt nur ein paar Black Ops ab.
Starten wir mal, wir können, wir können mal den Battle net klein, das bringt nix.
Okay, Leute, das war's für heute. Ich wünsche euch einen schönen Tag und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich hab gedacht, wenn ich jetzt quasi den Controller hab, die Xbox 360 wieder angeschlossen hab, dann könnten wir doch mal ne Runde Bad Company 1 Singleplayer durchspielen.
So, meine Tastatur. So irgendwann, so Sonntagvormittag oder so. Die Battle, die Bad Company 1 Kampagne. Die war nämlich mit Abstand die beste Battlefield Kampagne ever.
Das ist Bad Company 2. Auch Bad Company 2. Alles Bad Company 1. Beste. Die ist lustig. Die ist, nimmst dich nicht ernst. Die ist, hast du aus Freiheiten im Gameplay.
Also die ist echt geil gewesen. Ich hab die ja nur einmal gespielt damals, weil ich so auf Multiplayer Sachen gestanden hab. Und die war übelst geil, kann ich mich auch dran erinnern.
Vor allem gab's da irgendwie nen Golfplatz, wo die dann mit so nem Golfauto zum nächsten Einsatz gefahren sind. Das war übelst lustig gemacht.
Okay komm, wir probieren jetzt mal ob's tatsächlich, ob's jetzt vielleicht nicht abkackt. Äh, nicht jetzt. Nicht jetzt, instant. Das liegt daran, dass wir, dass wir hier Krill spielen.
Wir spielen ja, als wir spielen als Mason. Äh, war die Stimme irgendwie nicht ganz richtig für Mason gerade? Könnte das sein?
Okay, die stimmen, stimmen, stimmen, stimmen, stimmen nicht. Egal, deploy. Morgen, ich weiß nicht. Können wir vielleicht, vielleicht morgen.
Also ich muss ja erstmal meine Bad Company, oh nee, ich hab ne Idee. Moment. Moment. BC1 Backward Xbox One. Geht das?
Jawoll, wir können das sogar auf der Xbox One spielen. Das ist ja noch viel besser. Da kann ich mit der Xbox One wenigstens mal was machen.
Die steht seit Release hier und ist aus. Wir spielen jetzt einfach Backward Compatibility, spielen wir das. Ja, viel besser.
Und wahrscheinlich muss ich da nicht mal mal die CD suchen, weil man muss sich die Games ja doch, äh, man muss sich ja die Games irgendwie, hat jemand schon mal Backward Compatibility Spiele gespielt auf der Xbox One?
Man muss sich die Spiele ja irgendwie neu runterladen. Also die Original DVD geht ja nicht mehr.
Ist das wichtig, wenn man das auf seinem Account drauf hat, dass man sich runterladen kann oder braucht man die Original DVD?
Also, Construction Site. Volle Pulle.
Na, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Ha! Diesmal nicht.
Hier ist nichts.
Ich brauch ne Waffe. Hier ist nichts. Da unten war was. Ich hab's gesehen.
Ich brauche jetzt nur noch Helz.
Ich brauche Helz. Hier ist Helz.
Ich höre 50.000 Gegner neben mir. Die sind aber über mir, ne? Ich brauche Helz. Immer noch Helz.
Ok, jetzt gehen wir wieder hoch. Helz. Jawoll. Jetzt haben sie sich alle schon gegenseitig gebashed. Jetzt stellzen wir hier rein.
Alter, wie hoch ist denn das? Da rennst du ja 5 Stunden.
Alter, ich hab kein Wort mehr heute. Ich bin auch kacke gerade. Voll gerekt, Alter. Voll weggebashed.
Wie den letzten scheiß Kacknoob. So. Ich wollte ja schon vor 2 Stunden gefühlt aufräumen am Schluss.
Reicht schon heute.
Hast du schon mal einen, was? Irgendeinen Game Streaming Dienst getestet?
Ja, hab ich. Ich hab mal den allerersten probiert. Wie hieß denn das? War das OnLive? Oder ist OnLive die PS4 Geschichte gewesen?
Ich glaube, OnLive war das. Das habe ich ganz am Anfang. Ja, ich glaube, das war das. Das habe ich ganz am Anfang, als es neu war, mal ausprobiert.
Und da war es noch ziemlich laggy.
Das war nicht so toll.
Ja, mit so einem Zweifachscope auf die Range. Ich hätte wahrscheinlich einfach Spray and Pray aus der Hüfte.
Aber sobald man anfängt sich über das Game aufzuregen, spielt man eh kacke.
Hol dir EA Access für die Xbox One. Da sind alle Battlefields drin. Ja, ich hab das Game, ja.
Die DVD muss im Laufwerk sein.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal mit Company1 Disk suchen. Nein, jetzt kommt nicht mit Company1. Jetzt kommt... Ich gehe off.
Offline.
Das gibt es leider auch noch, immer noch. Trotz Always On von Spielen.
Na, wäre ich jetzt Partner, würde ich online bleiben. Easy Money, easy Live. Aber nachdem ich kein Partner bin, habe ich überhaupt nichts davon ab, dass ich streame.
Ja, könnte jetzt auch aufgehen. Nee, ich hab kein Wort mehr.
Habt ihr eigentlich den Nintendo Direct gesehen?
Mit den Wahnsinns Ankündigungen, mit diesen... Diesen bahnbrechenden News zu Switch Online.
Was? Sag mal, was ist diese EA Bullshit-Datei auf dem...
Das war für die... Das war für die E3. Stimmt.
Was war für die E3? Und wir haben ziemlich gut gelegen, ja? Ja, Auto auf der Bühne gab es leider nicht.
Stimmt. Was hatten sie denn? YouTuber oder C-Promi auf der Bühne? Wen hatten die da bei der E3 noch mal auf der Bühne? Sie hatten irgendjemand, das weiß ich, aber ich weiß nicht, war wer.
Wobei war der Moderator nicht selbst irgendein YouTube Grill? Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Wie heißt die Seite, wo die Streams archiviert sind? Ja, das ist eine Seite vom Sibaro, die heißt wubblords.tv oder alternativ maxfps.tv. Die ist nicht so schnell, die Seite, aber dafür ist sie kostenlos.
Ja, irgendwann geht die dann auf und dann gibt es hier so einen Archiv-Knopf und da ist dann der ganze Campell drinnen. Auch die E3-Dinger.
Leider nicht komplett alle, es geht bloß zurück irgendwie bis zum 17.9.2017. Ich habe schon ein bisschen früher angefangen, aber fast alle Streams sind da.
Ach, weil die Streams geladen werden. Aber man kann es verkraften. Ach, ernsthaft? Das habe ich noch gar nicht gelesen. Oh, mein Nintendo ist so unfähig.
Also genau, was ich euch zeigen wollte. Ja, glückliche Leute. Guckt ihr nicht auch immer so, wenn ihr Switch spielt? Immer. Ich sitze nicht etwa irgendwie entspannt da mit dem Controller in der Hand.
Nein, ich sitze da quasi und werfe mich so wie dieser Typ, der wirft sich so in das Game rein. Das machen die immer, wenn sie Werbung für Rennspiele haben. Dann haben sie immer die Typen vor dem Fernsehen sitzen und so.
Ja, links, rechts. Ja, links, rechts. Ja, Switch. Ja, das ist geil. So, was der Typ hier für Probleme hat, weiß ich auch nicht. Ich weiß von keiner Ahnung, was er hat.
Das wollte ich aber gar nicht zeigen. Zumindest sieht er aus irgendwie. Ich weiß nicht, was könnte man da reininterpretieren. Keine Ahnung. Noch nie den Fernseher gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht. Übrigens, seit wann spielt man Games so, wie die die Hände am Controller haben. Und ihr tut zumindest der Rücken weh. Nach 15 Minuten.
Ja, aber worauf ich eigentlich rauswolle. Oh, das wird ja immer. Das ist gefotoshopt. Die haben überhaupt nie nebeneinander gesessen, oder? Das Bild sieht gefotoshopt aus. Die zwei Typen und das Bild, die waren nie zusammen in einem Raum. Das sieht mega gefotoshopt aus, das Ganze hier.
So, wo ist das denn jetzt? Das ist nicht das, was ich euch zeigen wollte. Wo steht das denn? Preise. Steht vielleicht bei Preisen dabei. Übersicht über den Service. Vielleicht ist das...
Das ist doch grad das. Naja, zumindest hatten die halt irgendwie so ne Seite, wo halt angepriesen wird, wie geil Switch Online ist. Und da haben sie dann quasi, dass die Seite länger aussieht, haben sie dann die einzelnen NES-Spiele aufgelistet, die man mit Switch Online spielen kann.
Wo wir auch gedacht haben, ey. Ich mein, überlegt euch mal. Nintendo verkauft nen Online-Modus für ihre neueste Konsole, der quasi nichts kann, was nicht die erste Xbox konnte. Ob's jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen.
So, und die erste Xbox, wohlgemerkt, die erste Xbox ist natürlich nicht die Xbox 1, sondern die Xbox. Und das ist wunderbar zu googlen, da heutzutage dazu. Die kam 2002. Also sprich, Nintendo Switch Online ist im Kern. Auf dem Stand von 2002. Das ist natürlich ganz toll. Nintendo kriegt das ja nicht hin.
Ahja, warte mal. Ich glaub, das, was der Patrick geschrieben hat, das könnte sogar sein, die Seite. Ja, genau die. Das hier. Wo sie dann quasi so tun, als wär das was Geiles. Ich mein, ernsthaft. Ich mein, nen Online-Service, der quasi auf dem Niveau von der allerersten Xbox ist. So.
Und das Einzige, was sie irgendwie zusätzlich haben, und man davon abklären, dass die anderen Sachen auch schon nicht gut sind. Zum Beispiel, was bringt's dir, wenn sie krasse Server zur Verfügung stellen?
Aber Gamesme, Splatoon, was sie nur so das Online, nennen wir es mal auch, sogar eSport, also das Online-Competitive, Online-Aushängespiel, der Switch schlechthin ist. Abends haben sie ja schon beerdigt, mehr oder weniger drei Monate nach Release oder so. Warum noch immer. Wahrscheinlich hat's keiner gespielt.
Und das, das funktioniert ja schon mal nicht. Weil, was bringt dir die geile Server, wenn halt Splatoon im P2P ist und solche Dinge. Und quasi keiner, ja fast keine Vorgabe ist, das zu machen.
Und zumindest, das Einzige, was irgendwie sich noch hervorhebt, ist halt, dass du NES-Spiele spielen kannst. Ich mein ernsthaft, Nintendo, die Games sind 30 Jahre alt. Der NES kam, glaub ich, 83 oder so raus. Das Ding, das, oder?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Scheiße erzähle. Okay, 85. Ah, 85. Nee, 83. 83, sag ich doch, war ich doch gar nicht so schlecht. 83 kam der NES raus.
Da muss ich mal überlegen. Die verkaufen es als wahnsinnig geile neueste Errungenschaft und Fortschritt bei ihrem Switch, also quasi für den Online-Service ihrer neuesten Konsole, dass man 30 Jahre alte Spiele dabei kriegt.
Nicht etwa Super Nintendo-Spiele oder NES oder N64-Spiele oder vielleicht sogar mal ein Gamecube-Spiel oder vielleicht sogar mal, ja, Gott helfe, ein Wii-Spiel oder ein Wii U-Spiel oder so. Wobei, die Wii U-Spiele müssen sie ja remakeen jetzt mit den nächsten Jahren für die Switch.
Nein, NES-Spiele. Komm, Nintendo, das kann es doch echt nicht sein. Vor allem, die Spiele sind so alt. NES-Spiele ist das Problem, die Dinger sind so alt, Leute, die sie damals nicht gespielt haben, wollen sie heute nicht spielen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass quasi jemand, der mit Games der aktuellen Generation aufgewachsen ist, dass der wirklich Donkey Kong spielen will. Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass der großartig Bock hat, irgendwelche ollen, komischen NES-Sportgames zu spielen oder irgendwelche Puzzle-Games oder das erste Mario.
Das erste Mario, vielleicht doch einfach, dass man es mal gesehen hat, ja. Nee, das da. So, und das erste Teller, vielleicht, dass man es gesehen hat, aber so wirklich Bock auf diese Games haben Leute heute eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Was sage ich denn? Sie haben sie damals gespielt und die Leute, die sie damals gespielt haben, muss man sich mal überlegen, die hatten damals einen NES, haben Nintendo Kohle gegeben und die Spiele damals waren auch übelst teuer.
Wenn ich mich gerade erinnere, NES-Super-Nintendo-Spieler 120 Mark gekostet. Das ist klar, kannst du sagen, okay, sonst der Hälfte, 60 Euro. Es war unverhältnismäßig viel teurer als heute ein Game.
Und die haben die Spiele quasi damals schon gekauft, haben sie sich zwischenzeitlich wahrscheinlich nochmal gekauft auf dem Online-Store vom DS, vom 3DS, von der Virtual Console, von der Wii, von der Wii U und sowas. Die haben diese Games quasi drei, viermal schon gekauft.
Und jetzt dürfen sie sie quasi nochmal kaufen. Jawoll, Nintendo, da haben die Leute wahrscheinlich schon alle drauf gewartet. Das ist echt, weiß nicht, was mit Nintendo los ist. Das ist halt das für Echtfälle.
Hat Nintendo nicht eine Emulator-Seite abgemahnt? Ja, haben sie. Fandest du COD demnach schlecht? Nö. Ich musste erst mal noch ein bisschen spielen. Vor allem habe ich halt die letzten paar Runden übelst kacke gespielt.
Und auch eben so dämlich an den Stellen getroppt. Die ersten Runden liefen richtig, also wir hatten auch richtig gute Runden dabei. Nö, so schlecht finde ich das gar nicht.
Ja, uninstall Simulator, weil ich Battlefield uninstalled habe, noch während der Beta. Also ich werde das auf jeden Fall nicht uninstallen. Bis die Beta vorbei ist, aber die Beta läuft ja bloß noch. Quasi morgen, wenn du es so willst.
Eineinhalb Tag oder so noch, dann ist schon wieder vorbei. Ja, aber das finde ich echt fail. Also keine Ahnung, was mit Nintendo da los ist.
Und wenn man sich mal anguckt, ich meine, man bekommt im Oktober ein Mario Golf Spiel vom NES. Yeah, dafür hat es sich aber gelohnt. Man bekommt irgendwelche Games, von denen ich noch nie was gehört habe, außer Metroid.
Man bekommt noch mehr Games, von denen ich... Ach, keine Ahnung, komm, lassen wir es bleiben. Nintendo und Online ist einfach ein Ding, was nicht zusammenpasst. Kriegen sie es nicht hin. Ich meine, sie müssten ja im Prinzip einfach nur gucken, wie macht das Microsoft...
Wie hat das Microsoft offer 360 gemacht? Und dann wird es einfach nachbauen. Sonst nichts. Aber das kriegt Nintendo nicht hin.
Tja, nein, er crash das Game bei mir öfters. Das ist jetzt bestimmt die letzten fünf Runden dreimal gecrashed. Tja, gut.
Ja, früher habe ich immer gesagt, die beste Kombination ist ein Gaming-PC und eine Nintendo-Konsole einfach für die Nintendo-Spiele, weil da hast du eh keine Chance, dass die auf den PC kommen. Mittlerweile bei den meisten großen Spielen, die meisten großen Spielen sind ja mittlerweile Multiplattformen, die Nintendo-Spiele waren es halt nie.
Aber mittlerweile, es gibt ja auch für die Switch, und ich weiß, das ist jetzt was, was viele nicht so sehen, aber im Prinzip gibt es für die Switch jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele Sachen, die mich vom Hocker hauen.
Es gibt, also, must have gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Spiele. Das ist das neue Mario und das ist das neue Zelda. Jeder, der eine Switch hat, braucht das Ganze im Endeffekt. Fertig. So, du hast da noch ganz gute Spiele, ja, du hast Fire Emblem, du hast Xenoplade, du hast Splatoon...
Guck mal. Guck mal mal. Ah, du hast Splatoon, du hast Mario Tennis, das hier ist auch ganz nett. So, und dann, danach hast du halt nicht mehr so wirklich so die krassen must have Spiele, sondern einfach nur, wo du sagst, ok, wenn einem so diese Genre und so, wenn einem das gefällt, dann ja abends quasi schon wieder komplett mehr oder weniger eingestellt haben.
So, und das war es dann im Großen und Ganzen. Also, eigentlich gibt es nur zwei must have Titel und ich finde, das ist auch relativ wenig für die Konsole. Also, ich sehe auch keinen großen Grund dafür, sich eine Switch wegen den Games zu kaufen.
Der, finde ich, beste Grund, sich eine Switch zu kaufen ist, weil man die Features der Switch mag, also, dass man das mitnehmen kann. Aber das brauche ich nicht, weil ich habe unterwegs immer ein Smartphone dabei und man kann ja bis heute, glaube ich...
Hat die Switch mittlerweile einen Browser, eigentlich? Ich will nicht zwei Sachen mitnehmen. Hat die eigentlich mittlerweile einen Browser? Ja, die sind versteckend über die WLAN-Settings, den kenne ich. Ich meine, offiziell haben die sowas mittlerweile.
New Features, Internet-Bros, oh mein Gott, Nintendo 2018 bietet einen, nein, bieten sie ja leider nicht. Egal, ich könnte jetzt da ewig rumflamen über Nintendo, scheiß drauf. Das ist vorbei.
Ja, Max, Execution allerdings nur, wenn man breit gefächerte Interessen auf der Switch hat. Also, das muss einem quasi so Sachen gefallen wie Splatoon und Xenoplade gleichermaßen, was ja schon zwei komplett unterschiedliche Spiele sind.
Wenn es der Fall ist, hat man bestimmt genug auf der Switch, aber insgesamt, für mich gibt es außer Mario & Zelda eigentlich keine Spiele, wo man sagen muss, ja, dafür muss man unbedingt eine Switch kaufen.
Aber zumindest, um zurück zu kommen, Nintendo Online ist einfach Fail. Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit dem los ist. Leider, ja. Gut, Leute, machen wir Schluss. Mal gucken, ob ich morgen noch mal eine Runde Blackout streme.
Ich werde auf jeden Fall auf Stream noch ein bisschen spielen, mir ein paar ordentliche Dropspots angucken und generell einfach mal ein bisschen warm werden mit dem Game. Das geht ja im Stream immer relativ schwierig.
Gut, Leute. Oh, ich muss ja meine Outro-Musik noch spielen. Oh, wir machen jetzt Let It Go. Nein, aber nicht. Wir machen meine Outro-Musik, zack.
So, Leute. Wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht's gut. See you. Wahrscheinlich bis morgen oder so. Mal gucken.
Und entweder spiele, entweder, also wenn ich Bock habe auf Blackout, wie gesagt, ich spiele es jetzt ja auf Stream noch ein bisschen, dann spielen wir mal mit Blackout. Wenn ich meine, wenn ich keinen Bock auf Blackout habe und meine Bad Company 1 DVD finde, dann spielen wir die Bad Company 1 Singleplayer-Kampagne. Geht nicht so lang, 5 Stunden oder so.
Mal gucken. Oder vielleicht auch nichts. Wollen wir mal schauen. Also macht's gut. Bis denn. See you.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.